[Musique]
14h sur public sénat bonjour et
bienvenue à tous pour votre rendez vous
du mercredi les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
dans une heure vous connaissez le
principe par coeur les sénateurs vont
interpeller l'exécutif sur les sujets
chauds du moment et y en a beaucoup tout
le monde est en place vous allez le voir
jérôme rhabiller dans l'hémicycle jérôme
bonjour sur quoi le gouvernement va
devoir rendre des comptes aujourd'hui
demandez le programme il est là il est
complet il est varié pour courir tous
les sujets d'actualité avec tout de même
un focus sur les pandora paper ces
révélations sur l'évasion fiscale à
grande échelle ça va secouer merci
jérôme cantin chalmé est aussi avec nous
il est en salle des conférences bonjour
quand vous allez interroger ministre et
sénateur qui allez-vous avoir à votre
micro quentin on va revenir cette
proposition socialiste de rendre
obligatoire la vaccination tout contre
locaux vides 19 pendant parlera avec
bernard jomier rapporteur du texte tout
à leurs contingents masse y est aussi
avec nous ce thriller politique sur la
plateforme twitch bonjour vous allez
suivre ces questions d'actualité au
gouvernement avec votre communauté jean
et oui bonjour steve on a hâte de suivre
cette séance des questions au
gouvernement avec les internautes en
direct sur twitter tout l'après-midi à
toute allure gens au programme de cette
première heure la réforme de l'assurance
chômage qui prévoit un durcissement du
calcul des allocations cette réforme
elle est entrée en vigueur la semaine
dernière mais elle fait toujours débat
les syndicats ne baissent pas les bras
et dénoncent une réforme injuste qu'en
pensent les élus nécessaires pas
nécessaire utile pas utile cette réforme
alors que la croissance repart on en
débat à 14h30 avec sophie calle polian
sénatrice écologiste du val de marne et
martin lévriers sénateurs r&d pays la
république en marche des yvelines
[Musique]
mais d'abord mais d'abord au tour sur
cette onde de choc dans l'église
catholique au moins deux cent seize
mille victimes mineures ont été
agressées sexuellement par des membres
du clergé depuis les années 50 c'est la
conclusion d'un rapport accablant n'y a
pas d'autres mots publiés hier par une
commission indépendante
alors quelle suite donner à ce constat
glaçant les pouvoirs publics le
gouvernement les élus comptent ils
peuvent t'ils doivent-ils se saisir de
cette question est comment on en débat
dans un instant juste après ces éléments
d'explication signé cécile 6 ou regardé
hier jean-marc sauvé a symboliquement
transmis son rapport aux représentants
religieux mais concrètement que vont ils
faire de ces 45 recommandations
touchés par les conclusions accablantes
de la commission beaucoup ont déjà
exprimé leur désir de travailler pour
une reconnaissance de l'institution
comme responsables des abus sexuels
étaient surtout un changement de
mentalité et qu'il faut opérer vous
savez c'est toujours ce qu'ils aiment le
plus lent a changé ce sont les
mentalités je crois que maintenant il
faut qu'ils aient eu une attention
mutuelle on est avertis maintenant on
peut plus dire qu'on ne savait pas outre
chantier recommandé par la commission
l'indemnisation des victimes en mars
dernier l'église a ouvert un fonds de
dotation appelant aux dons des religieux
et des fidèles mais cette solution qui
fait payer les pratiquants ne correspond
pas aux conclusions de la commission
sauvé pour elle il faut que ce soit les
agresseurs et d'églises qui payent leur
mission très difficile parce que toutes
les ressources que nous avons ce sont
des dons des fidèles nous n'avons aucune
autre ressource que nous avons aussi des
du patrimoine le patrimoine une grande
partie notre patrimoine ce sont des sons
des bâtiments d'usagé sont des églises
de dawn of war ii sont peu ne sont pas
vendables n'ont pas donc n'ont pas
d'intérêt parti architectural
particulier donc c'est pas absolument
une solution enfin la levée du secret
des confessions des mineurs abusés
semble difficile à accepter pour
certains religieux quand un enfant au
cours
d'une confession va faire part en disant
ben
voila moi je suis peut-être je suis
amusé à demander à cet enfant dont il a
fini sa confession si vous voulez de
fender parlé avec quel soin d'inviter
cet enfant un peut-être une tierce
personne parce que je pense que c'est
important que le prêtre joue pas tous
les rôles les représentants religieux
qui doivent se réunir en novembre
prochain annonceront des premières
mesures à cette date pour en parler
pendant des badges et le plaisir
d'accueillir sur ce plateau dominique
vert et un bonjour sénatrice centriste
de llo demande de la commission des lois
merci d'être avec nous et également sur
ce plateau jean pierre mignard bonjour
vous êtes avocat et céistes de
téléspectateurs de public sénat vous
connaissent très bien michel magne et
également avec nos bons jours sénatrice
socialiste de loire-atlantique membre de
la commission des affaires sociales et
anthony favier bonjour vous êtes docteur
en histoire et membre de la rédaction de
témoignage chrétien ma première question
s'adresse à vous dominique vais rien
vous êtes avec michel meunier d'ailleurs
et la sénatrice qui républicain marie
mercier l'auteur d'un rapport sur les
infractions sexuelles commis sur mineurs
s'étaient publié en 2019 ce rapport
quelle est votre première réaction déjà
à ce rapport sauvé qui est accablant il
faut lire alors il est accablant
malheureusement pour nous qui avons fait
ce rapport que vous évoquiez il n'est
pas une surprise puisque nous imaginions
bien cela dans l'église mais d'ailleurs
et c'est vrai que notre mission
d'information s'intéressait à tous les
lieux d'accueil des enfants et on voit
bien qu'il ya un grand travail à faire
nous invitions d'ailleurs dans nos
propositions l'église à se saisir de ce
sujet et à le traiter nous invitions
l'église à donner les moyens à la
commission sauvé de faire ce travail et
au moins deux noms recommandations ont
été
oui voilà juste et puis appliquée
puisque le rapport et l'a effectivement
accablant mais ce qu'il faut souhaiter
aujourd'hui c'est que de l'église s'en
saisissent vraiment
que les pratiques puissent se stopper
anthony favier pour vous c'est pas une
surprise non plus ce rapport
malheureusement ce rapport commence à
s'inscrire dans une longue suite
d'autres rapports qui ont été fait dans
d'autres pays on avait déjà vu un
rapport en allemagne on avait déjà eu un
rapport en réalité 2 en irlande la
commission royale australienne avait
avait aussi investiguer dans l'église
catholique
le grand jury de pennsylvanie aux etats
unis avait aussi révélé des choses
concernant l'église catholique ce que
veut dire c'est que ça change et en fait
on fait des rapports mais alors on
évolue vraiment rien ne change vraiment
connaissant je ne dirais pas ça parce
qu'au début des années 2000 un je vous
rappelle la grande enquête de du boston
globe c'est 2000 2001 on pensait que
c'était des brebis galeuses au sein de
l'église catholique ensuite on a pris
conscience que c'était un système ce que
c'était system et khaled ges candidats
laura pour sauver moi ce qui m'intéresse
désormais avec le profilage qu'ont
réussi à faire les analystes du rapport
c'est que ya quand même une spécificité
catholique dans la pédocriminalité
les deux les victimes sont
principalement des garçons d'une
certaine tranche d'âge ce qui n'est pas
du tout équivalent dans la société
civile donc on passe de quelque chose de
systémique à quelque chose qui est très
particulier et qui demandent sûrement
interrogations et réflexions de la part
des autorités ecclésiastiques michel
meunier vous demandiez vous et votre
groupe une commission d' enquête sur la
pédophilie dans l'église en 2018 ça a
débouché sur une mission d'information à
ce qu'une commission d'enquêté aurait
permis de changer les choses est de
prendre les choses un peu plus en amont
la commission denquête en tout cas ce
qui a été révélé hier c'est que dans
l'église et le deuxième lieu après la
famille
lieu où les violences sexuelles sur
enfants ont leur plus grande réalité
après l'éducation nationale les loisirs
là j'ai tout ce qui est autour des
sports vient bien en deux après dans les
institutions l'église apparaît comme la
première
institution sociale sion voilà social
est organisée
abritant donc des agresseurs en son sein
jean pierre mignard je me tourne vers
vous à présent le rapport sauvé on
l'évoqué tout à l'heure décrit un
phénomène je cite massif et systémique
comment at-on pu laisser prospérer ce
phénomène en france précédent dossier
massif
systémique et gens s'y sentent démunis
et c'est sans doute d'ailleurs alors je
suis d'accord avec tout ce que d'un
sénatrice mais vous avez dit monsieur
favy mais l'aspect systémique qui à mon
avis le le tournant je veux dire de ce
rapport par rapport à tout ce qui a pu
être fait avant d'abord c'est un rapport
très honorable de genre dans la probité
doit être saluée parce que quand même
sinon on est on est on va terminer
neurasthénique de quoi donc ça rapport
d'une extrême probité il dit systémique
ce qui effectivement est un mot simple
mais qui renvoie à l'organisation de
l'église quand vision d'avenir c'est
vrai la famille et l'église c'est quoi
deux milieux fermés c'est à dire que
nous avons à faire une criminalité dans
des lieux fermés ce qui renvoie
effectivement par la famille son
organisation c'est même ce qui renvoie
aussi à l'organisation de l'église aussi
puisque ça signifie l'oma site l'opacité
ça signifie la maman de pézan un monde
du silence et je pense carrément d une
défini de notation sociologique est
importante et sans que beaucoup des
victimes s'il s'agit de victimes
appartenaient pour moitié à des enfants
revenant de classe défavorisée c'est à
dire dont les parents n'étaient pas
susceptibles d'être des relais actif
connaissant et surtout ayant l'audace de
pouvoir poser des questions donc ce
rapport est majeur il ya avant ce
rapport et y est après faut quand même
le reconnaître qu'il dira c'est
essentiel pour vous il ya un avant après
oui bien sûr bien sûr en france c'est
majeur vous utilisez aussi je crois le
mot systémique dans votre rapport de
mission d'information qu'est ce que ça
implique comme on vous l'interprétez
vous
notamment dans le système et comment le
système peut se mettre en place nous
avions déjà perçu qu'il pouvait y avoir
un billet au moment du recrutement
ou un jeune vient pour dire qu'il veut
devenir prêtre et là effectivement il
peut y avoir un billet le biais c'est
éventuellement quelqu'un qui est déjà
pédophiles et prédateurs et qui va venir
dans un lieu où il ya des enfants mais
il y a aussi probablement le bien de la
personne qui sent déjà que elle a une
sexualité qui est pas tout à fait
conforme et qui souhaitent s'en prémunir
et le meilleur moyen de s'en prémunir
c'est de s'interdire toute relation
sexuelle en devenant prêtre sauf que
combien de temps ça peut tenir et donc
là on sent qu'il peut y avoir vraiment
un biais dans le recrutement et qui peut
créer un système est d'ailleurs la
commission sauvé le note et dit qu'il va
falloir faire très attention
aux gens qui vont se présenter et à
veiller à ne pas avoir ce genre de
profil alors j'aimerais qu'on n'écoute
à présent une association de victimes
que vous connaissez bien la parole
libérée la parole libérée qui demandent
clairement que les responsables payent
pour leur acte écouter la première étape
de la reconnaissance de responsabilité
le premier processus et qui est loin de
se suffire à lui tout seul c'est
l'indemnisation des victimes voilà donc
effectivement
ce point n'est pas négociable
anthony favier qui doit être tenu pour
responsable on va parler bien sûr de
l'indemnisation mais qui doit être
vraiment tenu pour responsable parce que
c'est l'auteur de ces crimes est ce que
c'est l'église dans son ensemble pendant
longtemps comme il y avait cette théorie
de la brebis galeuse ou du de la pomme
pourrie du panier l'église avait beau
jeu de dire qu'il fallait surtout s'en
prendre à la personne individuellement
est pénalement responsable claire
délictueux
maintenant on voit qu'on passe à une
autre dimension en réalité parce que là
et comme l'a rappelé jean marc sauvé on
a un problème qui est lié à la façon
dont l'église elle même sur plusieurs
décennies à gérer la situation soit en
déplaçant les personnes incriminées soit
on nous vend pas en interne des mesures
disciplinaires qui était prévu par le
droit canonique et qui n'ont parfois pas
été fait et on eu surtout parfois il le
document très bien dans le rapport ne
signalant pas au procureur certaines
situations donc quand on est sur six
décennies de manquement et de choses qui
ne conviennent pas il me semble en effet
possible de conclure à la responsabilité
de l'institution en tant que tel
l'horloge église l'église à moi je ne
suis pas fin juriste parce que l'église
ya des associations diocésaines il ya
des congrégations juris à côté d'eux
josé répétition depuis peu jean paul ii
puis benoît 16 on a fait remonter au
vatican tous les crimes relatifs à la
pédophilie donc du coup il était au
courant de certaines choses aussi moi je
sais pas c'est à mon avis c'est très
compliqué d'un point de vue de deux
juristes donc qu'il va falloir voir qui
est responsable mais me semble que
l'institution église dans les formes
qu'elle s'incarne dans notre loi on peut
être tenu comme responsable à la fois au
civil et au pénal parce que il va
falloir aussi indemnisées et puis tout
où toutes les personnes qu'on voit
françois devaux la philippique qu'il a
fait hier
quand il a dénoncé les pharisiens on
voyait la souffrance dans sa vie qui a
trait qu'il y avait une souffrance telle
alors qu'il a accompli des choses
formidables à caparo libérer y sont fait
tomber le père prenne à ils ont une
audience que aucune victime jusque là
n'avait obtenu et on voit encore qui
porte en lui cette souffrance et cette
souffrance elle appelle réparation jean
pierre mignard à ce que des poursuites
devant les diocèses sont possibles je
sais pas vous mais moi je pense qu'il
faut aller jusqu'au bout s'ils nous font
pas des déviances les déviances et le
poids est effectivement prise en charge
par l'institution ce serait une forme
d'éthique canonique qui aurait été
transgressés il s'agit d'infractions
s'agit d'infractions comme devant de la
république ben oui bien sûr c'est une
loi de la république qui doit
s'appliquer src le droit commun
et donc d'ailleurs je vois que dans
parmi les 45 recommandations du rapport
seront sauvés que l'église doit endosser
une responsabilité à caractère à la fois
individuelle est systémique la
responsabilité juridique tant pénal que
civil vaut à titre individuel à raison
des fonctions exercées
comme pour l'ensemble des personnes
morales composent l'église est-ce que
des propositions à portsmouth alors ça
c'est très intéressant ce peut être une
responsabilité pour les fautes
personnelles choristes mais aussi du
fait d'autrui en raison du lien
juridique existe entre le prêtre auteur
du crime ou du délit et l'éveil de son
diocèse donc sur ce point il y a même
dans les préconisations du rapport sauvé
une indisponibilité du lien pénale entre
le prêtre et l'éveil dès lors que
celui-ci savait donc on est typiquement
dans une situation où le juge pénal
devraient apprécier la responsabilité
non seulement de l'auteur mais de
l'évêque qui savaient qui n'a rien dit
voyez donc on est bien sur l'implant qui
celui du droit commun alors on va
continuer à en parler dans quelques
instants le pape françois a réagi la
fait pas fière de son immense chagrin à
la suite des révélations il parle
aujourd'hui de honte il parle de honte
aujourd'hui le pape françois que la
sénatrice les républicains mari merci a
rencontré c'était il ya une dizaine de
jours dans le cadre de la délégation
d'amitié france vatican quant à calmer
vous êtes avec la sénatrice marie
mercier qui était la semaine dernière un
steve au vatican effectivement alors
pour évoqué de nombreux sujets mais
peut-être un mot de réaction à cette
déclaration du pape qui a dit à
plusieurs reprises sa honte qu'elle
voulait penser de ce message oui sa
honte je pense que c'est le bon bout la
honte et l'humiliation que l'église
n'ait pas su voir plus tôt tous ces
grands malheurs qui nous on nous a aussi
anéanti quand vous saluera la remise du
rapport oui j'avais absolument et nous
étions tous abasourdis devant c'est bien
évidemment ce nom considérable de
victimes mais surtout les dégâts inouïe
qui sont fait humainement sur tous ces
jeunes garçons puisqu'en l'occurrence
c'est plus de jeunes garçons alors
quelle va être la réponse de l'église
est ce que le travail des évêques est
aujourd'hui suffisant pour améliorer la
situation façon structurelle déjà les
élèves qu'ils ont demandé ce rapport
c'est bien à eux qui sont à l'origine de
cette énorme enquête pour moi vraiment
il faut qu'ils arrivent à dans la
formation des futurs prêtres déterminer
le discernement vocationnelle pourquoi
tel individu à cette motivation d'aller
vers la prêtrise où est la motivation
profonde de façon comme ça devrait être
fait d'ailleurs dans l'éducation
nationale et ailleurs de façon à savoir
vraiment pourquoi un adulte va est en
contact direct avec des enfants est
fréquemment et pourquoi recherche est il
sain pas alors qu'il ya dans ce contexte
des propos de monseigneur eric de
moulins beaufort que vous connaissez
bien et qui vous étiez notamment au
vatican président de la conférence des
évêques de france qui parle d'un secret
de la confession je cite plus fort que
les lois de la république c'est in
entendable cet argument au lendemain de
la remise du rapport sauvé alors je ne
n'ai pas entendu dire ça mais je crois
peut-être effectivement que ce qu'il
veut dire c'est que il faut un espace où
les fidèles puissent livrer puisse
libérer leur parole si en entrant dans
un dans un confessionnal ils se disent
que ce qu'ils vont révéler va être tout
de suite sur la place publique peut-être
ça va débloquer et je fais un peu le
parallèle avec mon métier quand vous
avez un patient qui vous livre un secret
vous d'abord vous garder ce secret est
ensuite qu'est ce que vous devez faire
convaincre le patient ou le fidèle bien
évidemment de dénoncer s'il faut
dénoncer et s'il s'agit d'un prêt de
convaincre ce prêtre d'aller expliquer
devant son échec et que ce soit le droit
commun qui s'applique salir les lois de
la république
bien évidemment mais donc l'église dans
ces cas là ne joue pas le rôle de est
bien de révélateur des affaires s'il
faut attendre que ce soit et bien le
perpétrer truc qui qui qui ce qui sort
lui-même l'information
on va avoir une limite très rapidement
dans la structure de l'église alors on
va avoir une limite donc l'idée c'est
effectivement qu'il y en ait qui en ait
plus de ce genre d'affaires faire en
sorte qu'ils aient des formations qui
est des repérages des diagnostics et
qu'on en arrive pas à la situation
abominable à laquelle
faisons face actuellement à laquelle
l'église s'efface ce qui me semble mais
vraiment j'y crois profondément c'est
nous sommes en république c'est le droit
commun qui s'applique quand on agresse
un enfant ce n'est pas un pêché c'est un
crime autrefois on parlait d' atteinte à
la chasteté pour l'agresseur maintenant
on parle d'agression à la dgi pour la
victime il faut se re bien se mettre en
tête que là il s'agit de s'occuper des
victimes merci merci merci et on a
entendu l émotion particulière dont l'un
qui voilà qui vous anime aujourd'hui et
depuis la remise hier ce rapport sauvé
merci merci beaucoup quand on a entendu
un marie mercier bien la justice des
hommes la justice des dieux mais
peut-être qu'on va parler ici la justice
des hommes avec notamment vous madame
mais d'amener les sénatrices sur tous
les faits qui ont été recensés par la
commission sauvé seule une vingtaine
sont encore ne sont pas encore prescrits
c'est à dire qu'on peut encore
finalement poursuivre leurs auteurs est
ce qu'il faut c'est notamment une des
réclamations à de certaines associations
est ce qu'il faut faire sauter cette
prescription sur ce genre de fait michel
meunier peut-être pour commencer moi je
veux bien commencé parce que là dessus
elle est de trente ans je crois après
les faits aujourd'hui voilà donc un pas
supplémentaire après la majorité depuis
la loi schiappa de 2018 un pas
supplémentaire de fait mais moi je suis
pour l'imprescriptibilité je le suis
depuis très longtemps l'imprescribilité
prescrit petit billy tu es et s il
fallait enfin le cias hier nous l'a
démontré c'est que le témoignage des
victimes a bien au delà et jean-marc
sauvé a même une pensée à la fin pour
toutes les victimes qui n'ont pas pu
s'exprimer parce qu'elles n'ont pas
trouvé la force ou simplement parce
qu'elles ne sont plus voilà mais je
voulais simplement revenir parce que
c'est là où il ya 10 ans us pour pas
dire contradiction entre nos personnes
rapporteur sur le travail c'est que je
pense que du point de vue
de la victime n'y a pas de secret il
peut pas y avoir de secret il faut qu'il
y ait faute à la confession secret de la
confession secret professionnel aussi
que nous connaissons dans le médical et
paramédical il n'y a pas de secret il y
à la violence qu'a subi la victime et
qui doit pouvoir s'exprimer françois
devaux a permis avec son association de
faire sortir et d'organiser les victimes
autour de leur parole mais pour tout à
l'heure pour revenir sur le système tous
ces éléments que sont le déni l'omerta
la transformation la protection de son
institution avant que celle de la
victime fonctionne est temps qu'elles
fonctionneront le système louis pourra
lui perdure et 2020 sur cette question
de la prescription et ensuite j'aimerais
vous écoutez jean pierre mignard
peut-être alors j'ai un avis différents
sur la prescription alors pas
spécifiquement en fait qu'est ce que
c'est que la prescription c'est un droit
à l'oubli parce que la justice au départ
s'occupait essentiellement de la société
et d'apaiser la société il un seul crime
est imprescriptible c'est le crime
contre l'humanité puisque là c'est le
genre humain qui est clairement menacée
et c'est la collectivité et la société
qui est directement menacée ensuite il y
a effectivement une prescription qui
maintenant pour les crimes sexuels donc
plus que pour tout autre crime est de 30
ans après la majorité donc pour les
crimes sexuels sur mineurs ce qui fait
que effectivement un mineur a jusqu'à
ses 48 ans ensuite pour pouvoir porter
plainte ça le met au delà de tout autre
crime qui normalement est de 20 ans pour
la prescription donc déjà on a créé nous
dans la loi une espèce d'ordre de
du mal en dix ans le crime sexuel c'est
pire que le crime tout court donc si
jamais on devait faire sauter la
prescriptive édité pour le crime sexuel
alors faudrait la faire sauter pour
d'autres crimes parce que effectivement
détruit quelqu'un et ça on peut pas
ignorer que la victime est profondément
meurtri c'est donc on détruit quelqu'un
avec un crime sexuel mais quand on l'a
tué on l'a aussi sûrement détruit alors
soit c'est plus qui souffrent
aujourd'hui mais il a laissé des enfants
un parent que sèche donc quand on a tué
mon enfant est ce que j'ai le droit là
j'ai le droit à la prescription et si
jamais on la violer je n'ai plus de
prescription donc il va falloir faire
une échelle du mal pour savoir où il ya
ou non prescription pour vous c'est non
il sait choisir quelle société on veut
est-ce qu'on a une société dans laquelle
on a un droit de l'oubli ou pas et si on
décide qu'il ya pas de droit de l'oubli
il ya un droit à l'oubli pour rien mais
quelle société ça va nous donner la
commission est en tout cas pour le statu
quo visiblement sur cette question de la
prescription était qu'est ce que vous en
pensez oui je pense que le débat que
vous vous tenez tant des balles
philosophie juridique est politique
criminelle tout à fait légitime mois
concrètement se pose la question avec le
temps de la prescription celui des
preuves c'est à dire que plus on allonge
le temps de la prescription plus on
risque de se trouver à une situation où
la collection des preuves est difficile
et je pense que c'est peut-être moins la
question de la prescription dispose que
le silence qui entoure et je pense
notamment que le délit de non
dénonciation
puisque c'est quand même voulu l'avait
voté un quand même c'est un très bon
travail en matière si un mineur à moins
de 15 ans et trois ans de prison si on
ne dénonce pas si mineur à plus de 15
ans et cinq ans de prison la
prescription en agression sexuelle aux
atteintes sexuelles sur une heure dix
ans à compter de la majorité de la
victime viol sur mineure vingt ans à
compter de la majorité la victime
convenons d'ailleurs qu'un violeur qui
agresse puis continué d'agresser le
délai de prescription de la première
victime se rallonge à celui d'un
deuxième équipe donc la question c'est
vous c'est non c'est non aussi pas d'un
saut à fernand mais je crois que je vais
débat légitime sur ce point et moi que
j'ai pas tranchée mais par contre je
pense que c'est le crime de la
dénonciation c'est à dire est-ce que
alors là tout le monde chacun se sont
effectivement en charge de devoir
dénoncer
et fait donc il pense en tout cas qu'il
existe suffisamment d'un 10 qui peuvent
être graves et concordants pour protéger
l'enfant c'est ça c'est un débat que
nous avions eu et je suis d'accord avec
vous et c'est un débat visiblement à la
sias puisque là aussi la commission
demande justement à ce qui est la levée
dans ces cas là et bien sûr c'est à
friser mille fois raison parce qu'en
plus se pose le problème alors là la
confession on est en pole secret là
qu'on fait on est en plein dedans parce
que si un délit de non-dénonciation
je confesse je sais je ne dis rien alors
bien sûr je suis tenu par le ce c'est le
voeu que le film avec montgomery clift
la loi du silence je ne dois rien dire
enfin sinon je vais en infraction avec
le droit commun nous les avocats même
problème s'est accélérée une analogie on
assuré professionnels l'attention
lorsqu'on nous révèle qu'un crime et est
en train de se commettre qu il se commet
on n'a pas l'obligation de se taire on a
l'obligation d'aller voir notre
bâtonnier qui est une certaine manière
notre évêque allons très bien et c'est à
lui d'aller voir le procureur général
pour cent effectivement révélé faire en
sorte que l'infraction cesse le secret
de la confession est plus fort que les
lois de la république c'est ce qu'a
déclaré le président de la conférence
des évêques de france qu'est ce que ça
vous inspire entonné famille alors c'est
un débat comme celui de
l'imprescribilité du nom voir on
comprend bien le débat juridique et
philosophique mais le lendemain de la
remise d'un rapport qui dit que l'église
dont j'ai la repre dont je suis le à la
tête est responsable de plusieurs
centaines de milliers de victimes c'est
au minimum une maladresse au mieux une
faute morale voire pire je ne comprends
pas comment on arrive à poser ainsi le
débat quant lui a remis un tel rapport
qui porte un paragraphe explicitement
sur la question du secret de la
confession qui est très pondéré et qui
est très modérée parce que quand même
monsieur sauver ça a été un grand
serviteur de l'état au conseil d'état on
peut pas l'accuser de pas connaître les
lois de la république et l or il dans un
des paragraphes qui dit que dans le
respect
de d'une déontologie professionnelle du
sacerdoce on peut envisager de ne pas
respecter cette protection moi ce que ça
m'inspire en plus c'est que concrètement
les évêques ne gère pas les situations
au confessionnal je ne sais pas comment
on arrive et se débat le dire expliqué
nous je voudrais bien par exemple vous
êtes une famille de victimes votre
enfant a eu un souci avec un prête un
religieux vous allez vous plaindre à
l'évêque lévesque il va pas faire venir
à l'évêché sont prêtes pour le confesser
il va le faire venir et il va se
présenter à lui comme un supérieur qui
l'est par rapport à un subordonné en lui
demandant des comptes je vois pas jojo
je ne comprends pas c'est à dire que et
et le vatican a toujours il ya eu encore
un motu proprio du peuple françois
récemment pour dire dans cette situation
là il convient au supérieur l'ordinaire
donc soit le supérieur les vagues soit
le supérieur hiérarchique dans une
congrégation religieuse de signaler aux
autorités civiles peut imaginer quelle
image envoie monseigneur moulins
beaufort en disant ça on passe tout de
suite à la confession si confession il
ya ça veut dire qu'il ya pénitence mais
éventuellement absolution donc il en
train de faire passer le message que lui
déjà en train de donner l'absolution
alors que bon si quelqu'un a fait un
crime aussi grave qu'un crime sexuel je
pense qu'avant de penser à la confession
et lui donner une absolution peut lui
dire qu'il va falloir faire un certain
nombre de pénitence et de choses avant
d'être ramenés dans le peuple de dieu
2010 c'est pourquoi il y aura un avant
après ce rapport parce que dans les
recommandations de la commission il y a
aussi le fait de séparer bien les rôles
est de savoir qui est là pour diriger
spirituellement qui est là pour diriger
la congrégation rection cela les rituels
et pas la direction voilà
la direction humaine on va dire et donc
appartement où cette séparation est
demandée elle l'est aussi pour ça c'est
à dire que du coup on n'aura plus à
mélanger savoir si ces confessions ou si
c'est pas confession puisque on
mélangera pas le rôle de l'évêque et
d'où aussi ce qui est demandé c'est
d'avoir une cellule pour recueillir la
parole parce que l'important c'est que
la victime soit reconnue comme victime
et donc avoir une césure pour recueillir
la parole et qu'ils ne soient pas faites
avec des prêtres mais bien avec des
laïcs pour pouvoir bien séparées là
encore à qui on s'adresse et est ce que
c'est un maître spirituel ou à une
personne humaine qui va venir nous aider
mais chez le meunier le mot de la fin
cet immense travail de deux ans et demi
de la commission indépendante
là est mise à mal et vous avez raison de
parler de mauvais signal parce que déjà
on entend puissance us voire de la
contradiction
que va devenir ce rapport justement jean
marc sauvé nous a dit à l'ats d'hier il
aura pas de comité de suivi je passe le
relais
à donner sa réponse le mois prochain
voilà assez net donc maintenant
encore une fois si tous les évêques dans
l'eure
en droit se met à dire comme ça bon
essayons de réparer de monnayer enfin
j'aime moi je suis dubitatif pour pas
dire voilà inquiète sur la science 15 15
on aurait de surcroît sur un plan de
politique générale on devrait être sur
ce point intransigeant cette commission
va dans le sens de l'intransigeance et
de la probité alors que l'on demande
beaucoup à l'islam et on a raison de ne
pas le demander
au catholicisme est séparatiste
séparatisme ce sera le mot de la fin
merci beaucoup c'est la fin de ce débat
merci à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à ce débat les questions
d'actualité vont démarrer dans
exactement trente deux minutes
maintenant tout le monde est en place
vous allez le voir sur votre écran
quentin calmet et en salle des
conférences jean magicie sur twitch et
jérôme rabier qui est au coeur de la
machine jérôme vous êtes dans
l'hémicycle jérôme racontez-nous sur
quoi les sénateurs vont interpeller le
gouvernement dans 30 minutes maintenant
et bien il y aura trois crises trois
questions de trois groupes politiques
différents sur les révélations du
consortium international
les journalistes d'investigation les
pandora paper saint inspiré de la boîte
de pandore c'est le type de cette
enquête mondiale et il y aura donc trois
questions des spécialistes du sujet ici
au sénat eric boké pour le groupe
communiste nathalie goulet pour le
groupe centriste et thierry cozic pour
le groupe socialiste qui interrogeront
le gouvernement
merci beaucoup jérôme autre sujet un
sujet qui pourrait bien s'imposer comme
le thème principal de l'élection
présidentielle dans six mois je veux
parler bien évidemment du pouvoir
d'achat hier les salariés étaient
appelés par les syndicats à descendre
dans la rue pour demander des réponses
concrètes sur la question des salaires
mais dans les rangs de la manifestation
il était aussi question de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage la réforme entrée en
vigueur la semaine dernière regardait
sud sujet il est signé jordan klein
c'est sous une pluie battante
hier qu environ 25000 personnes ont
manifesté à paris 85 mille en france
l'appel de plusieurs syndicats dont la
cgt fo les revendications dans le
cortège était clair défendre les
salaires l'emploi appelait à une hausse
du smic mais aussi protester contre la
réforme de l'assurance chômage entrée en
vigueur vendredi dernier sur ce point
l'opposition ne faiblit pas et dénonce
notamment la nouvelle méthode de calcul
les syndicats ont annoncé attaqué devant
le conseil d'état ce nouveau volet de la
réforme tous les syndicats vont déposer
un recours d'ailleurs j'insiste sur le
fait que quand tous les syndicats sont
contre une réforme ou bien le
gouvernement qui parle beaucoup de
dialogue social et de concertation
l'appliquent quand même le gouvernement
tente de nous de faire croire que on est
chômeur par par désir on est chômeur par
envie je vous rappelle qu'il ya trois
millions de chômeurs qui ne touche
aucune indemnité et le gouvernement
essaie de nous dire qu'en baissant leurs
indemnités ils vont trouver plus
facilement du boulot passé 3 millions
qui ne toucherai devrait déjà avoir
trouvé du boulot d inquiétude aussi du
côté de la france insoumise leur crainte
voire des chômeurs être plus pénalisée
que d'autres comme ceux qui alterne les
périodes d'emploi et d'inactivité il
faut redire que cette réforme de
l'assurance chômage et injuste violente
que d'autres solutions existent y
compris pour relancer l'emploi dans ce
pays le chômage ça n'est pas la charité
quand vous êtes au chômage c'est parce
que vous avez cotisé pour une assurance
pour un risque en quelque sorte et le
gouvernement plastronne sur une reprise
économique qui serait absolument
formidable dit que le problème de
l'emploi finalement ce serait des
emplois non pourvus et le chômage
volontaire d'après l'unedic 1,15 million
d'allocataires toucheront dans l'année
qui suit la réforme une allocation
chômage plus faible et pour en parler
pour en débattre j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir sur ce plateau martin
lévriers bonjour sénateurs rdp la
république en marche des yvelines en
face de vous sophie calle polluants
bonjour la sénatrice écologiste du val
de marne ma première question s'adresse
à vous martin lévriers on entrevoit la
fin des crises sanitaires c'est le bon
moment de d'engager cette réforme elle
en vigueur depuis vendredi dernier le
rappel par excusez moi je suis content
que vous dit on entrevoit la fin d'harry
sanitaire moi je serai plus prudent ce
virus nous a tellement appris l'humilité
depuis deux ans qu'il faut être très
prudent en revanche sur l'a6
effectivement nous continuons dans cette
démarche d'une balade d'un virus qui qui
décroît de plus en plus fort oui la
reprise économique est forte où il
repose l'économie qui est très solide et
oui la france est très bien embarqué
dans cette reprise économique donc ça
c'est une très bonne nouvelle dr elles
sont au vert la réforme il faut que les
voyants sont au vert la réforme me
paraît très importante effectivement
parce que que je
j'entendais le dépit du tout à leur dire
on est au chômage contre le chômage
c'est parce qu'on a des droits non on
est au chômage parce qu'on a plus de
travail et l'épanouissement pour moi
passe par le travail le chômage n'est
pas un lieu d'épanouissement donc tout
doit être fait pour participer et
d'aider les personnes à sortir du
chômage c'est l'essentiel dans les
meilleures conditions possibles non mais
on a vécu de puiser des avec un coup de
pied haut depuis depuis 15 ans espèce de
chômage de masse et on s'en contente et
on accepte et 25% de jeunes au chômage
ça posait pas de question moi je ne suis
pas d'accord avec ça je crois vraiment
que le travail est un facteur
d'épanouissement et que tous ceux qui
contribuent à pousser les gens ou elle
ait incité parce qu'ils le font pas
c'est moi je ne crois pas à la volonté
d'être chômeur pour être chômeur ça je
n'y crois pas mais quand par défaut
finalement être au chômage est aussi
intéressant voire plus intéressant c'est
vrai ça il ya des gens pendant qu'il
reste vous avez vous je dis pas qu'il ya
des gens mais vous avez des cas très
précis de dessus de gens qui vont
travailler une semaine puis s'arrêter
une semaine où travailler un mois puis
travaillé à moi ou travaillé six mois
puis partir six mois vous les connais
moi j'en connais plein de gens qui par
vous en reparler mais le lien est qui
qui qui joue ce thème mais c'est pas
l'idéal c'est pas vraiment le sujet ce
qui me fascine toujours cette capacité à
pour les uns être hyper tatillon et pour
les autres n'y a pas de souci plein de
fois dans l'hémicycle on parle
optimisation fiscale
pour lutter contre l' optimisation et là
on me répond ah ben non ils ont droit il
se faufile entre dans une législation
compliqué donc façon et son port d clos
donc c'est normal et alors là parce que
il y aurait des salariés qui seraient
dans un certain nombre de secteurs dont
les métiers sont je dirais comme ça
soumis à des stop and go alors là ils
profiteront
si on est dans le droit et pour les
autres c'est
cette réforme c'est de faire deux
milliards d'économies sur le dos des
précaires aujourd'hui on a un
gouvernement qui
parle beaucoup d' équilibre budgétaire
qui lancent des chèques à chaque jour
différents à tel ou tel groupe de
pression ou perso ou voilà est par
contre ça pour faire des économies de
l'ordre de 2 milliards sur les plus
précaires ils sont là n'attendez matin
mais celle ci
est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on a une réforme qui a été
suspendu par le conseil d'état qui a été
suspendue qui a été suspendu par le
conseil d'état parce que au regard du
fait que la situation n'est pas
stabilisée et vous venez même de le dire
elle ne l'est pas complètement le
gouvernement aurait bien mieux fait
d'attendre effectivement que la requête
au fond soit analysé par le conseil
d'état pour pouvoir venir sauver c'est
très raisonnable mais répondre forêt
pour y répondre cette réforme c'est quoi
c'est pour créer des emplois ou c'est
pour faire des économies sur le budget
de la sécu si on voulait ford faire des
économies sur luge la sécu est-ce qu'on
garderait le même nombre de salariés à
pôle emploi alors qu'il ya de moins en
moins de chômeurs et nous le faisons est
ce que est ce que non non mais c'est
important est ce que est ce que nous
nous financerons des contrats pros pour
les chômeurs en très longue durée de
chômage à hauteur de 8000 euros ça fait
à peu près trente mille personnes qui
peuvent être concernées par ces contrats
est ce que saisir des économies non
c'est s'intéresser aux gens qui sont en
difficulté et des surtout qu'ils sont
ceux qui sont plus grande difficulté que
il y ait des économies sont fait excuser
moi c'est pas prêt m d'économies c'est
simplement du bon sens moyen chômeurs -
le coup le coup le coût du chômage est
important c'est juste basile donc il
s'agit pas de chercher à faire des
économies il s'agit de tout faire pour
ramener les gens à l'emploi et trouver
de l'emploi surtout dans une période
aujourd'hui vous le savez on a un delta
incroyable entre le nombre de d'offres
d'emploi il emploie n'en tourne alors
parlons-en justement ça c'est un
véritable problème juste une chose les
conseillers pôle emploi ont des
centaines de personnes à gérer dans leur
portefeuille donc même s'il y avait une
embellie pour avoir un accompagnement à
la hauteur des enjeux et personnalisés
il faudrait surtout pas baisser le
nombre de conseillers pôle emploi je
leur adresse tout mon soutien
connaître ils sont en grande souffrance
aujourd'hui les conseillers pour
l'auteur les quotidiens jusqu'aux
collines de personnes alors qu'on
devrait faire d accompagnement
individualisé excusez moi encore vous ne
baissez pas le nom d'agencé pôle emploi
heureusement qu'on le félin ça ne leur a
pas fait et je rappelle juste pour rien
juste important qualité mais serait
assez que cette ce décret intervient
maintenant et on retrouve des systèmes
qui sont à peu près équivalents à ceux
d'avant 2008 ça que finalement avant
2008 les systèmes de contrôle et
d'obtention de droit au chômage
etait-elle correspondent à peu à peu
près à ce qu'on trouve aujourd'hui donc
c'est un peu étonnant alors qu'on a de
moins en moins de chômeurs d'être
surpris qu'on dise non maintenant le
chômage il faut aller dans une logique
de la recherche d'emploi plutôt de
l'accompagnement précisément aujourd'hui
en france il ya des jobs il ya des
chômeurs mais entreprises elles peinent
à recruter comment vous expliquez ça
alors écoutez moi j'ai lu le dernier
rapport banque de france il ya un autre
rapport qui chiffre qui chiffre à 300
mille emplois
un autre qui dit 265000 il y a ça dépend
comment on prend les chemins tiers dans
l'hôtellerie restauration
non mais qui à trois millions de
chômeurs de catégorie b si je me
souviens plus et 6,7 millions quand on
prend tout le halo 300 milles 6 millions
donc moi je pense effectivement qu'il ya
une nécessité à faire en sorte que ces
emplois non pourvus trouvent preneurs
bien évidemment mais il faut pas à nous
laisser penser que le problème du
chômage en france serait résolu parce
alors comment les pourvois c'est quoi
votre sujet alors que selon moi je pense
qu'il ya nécessité que les employeurs
d'une part cesse de chercher des montots
à cinq pattes est effectivement se
disent investissent dans la jeunesse en
se disant je vais recruter un jeune
peut-être qu'il n'est pas au niveau de
compétences attendues immédiat mais on
va mettre en place un certain nombre de
choses pour faire en sorte que ça se
passe bien parce qu'aujourd'hui on voit
quand même que parmi ces trois cent
mille emplois ça tourne parce qu'il ya
plein en fait finalement ils abandonnent
c'est dommage je pense qu'il ya
énormément de choses aujourd'hui et deux
dans le service public de l'emploi pour
faire en sorte de deux matches et voilà
mais ça ne résoudra pas la difficulté
actuelle des demandeurs d'emploi et
notamment des plus précaires moi j'ai
rencontré dans la manifestation hier une
dame qui est guide touristique elle est
spéciale pour l'accueil des japonais
elle parle merveilleusement le japonais
elle a fait des études spécifiques pour
accueillir les japonais aujourd'hui a
pas de japonais donc on peut toujours
lui dire de traverser la rue ou de faire
je ne sais pas quoi il n'y a pas de
travail selon les compétences
extrêmement élevé de cette dame et là on
va lui réduire ses allocations elle va
être en grande difficulté pour payer son
gaz on sait pas si on va par l'énergie
cre ont valu ray directement pour qu'on
lirait durée ou es ce que vous avez vu
qu'on allait réduire d'abord si elle est
déjà au chômage rien ne sera réduit
puisque ça ne concerne que les personnes
entrantes à partir du 1er octobre alors
selon l'insee il ya quand même selon li
ning au total plus d'un million de
personnes plus d'un million de chômeurs
vont voir leurs revenus imputer de 17%
en moyenne selon elle il existe à partir
de l'année prochaine ap nommé à partir
de la prochaine pour ceux qui
rentreraient au chômage on peut aussi
espérer qui est de moins en moins de
gens qui rentrent au chômage ce qui est
un pari mais ça mais c'est un pari monde
la fille sur l'apprentissage on a réussi
souvenez vous on l'a fait ce droit du
travail et on a eu les mêmes critiques
des mêmes personnes et on l'a fait et on
a réussi à chaque fois on a réussi
pourquoi parce que là l'économie repart
vraiment le problème qu'on a aujourd'hui
aussi parmi d'autres mais je vous
rejoins certains points c'est aussi
l'inadéquation quoi qu'on en dise entre
les postes proposés et les formations
existantes et là c'est un véritable
sujet sur lequel il faut travailler qui
est un vieux sujet alors on le fait par
le biais de l'apprentissage de réforme
de l'apprentissage mais ça mais ça c'est
du long terme ou de salaire les deux les
deux avant tout c'est être con on
attirait peut-être plus non mais si je
n'avais pas les personnes qualifiées
quel que soit le salaire vous n'avez pas
les personnes qualifiées même si vous
pour vous un salaire de 200 mille euros
à une personne qui n'est pas qualifié et
ne pourra pas remplir le poste ça n'a
pas fonctionné comme ça donc il ya un
les qualifications 2 et là je vous
rejoins je pense qu'on sera d'accord
effectivement dia pour moi et je le
pense vraiment un problème de salaires
en france
le gouvernement a fait énormément
d'efforts en baissant les impôts en
baissant les charges sociales en
baissant les charges patronales aux
entreprises maintenant de prendre la
main c'est pas l'état c'est pas le
gouvernement qui fait le salaire ça
c'est possible sinon sinon sinon c'est
un système administré on sait comment ça
sur le smic mais le smic c'est le styx
et un point seul et vous savez bien que
travaillant sur la prime d'activité tel
qu'on l'a fait pour quelqu'un qui est au
smic maintenant il a un treizième mois
il dit donc c'est vrai un fn jean tous
les salaires derrière non c'est faux
malheureusement ça marche pas comme ça
malheureusement si vous avez un fernando
de resserrement et kinés qui n'améliore
pas les choses et voire d'explosion donc
non le smig mois ne paraît pas la bonne
solution en revanche que les entreprises
se prennent par la main visiblement le
secteur de l'hôtellerie de la
restauration a pris ce sujet à bras le
corps enfin j'allais dire ils l'ont fait
en 2000 je crois à 2008 où 2010 des jeux
une fois mais ça n'est pas suffisant il
a très bien mais que les entreprises
cette fois ci parce qu'elles ont été
aidées protégé comme on a protégé les
salariés pendant toute cette pandémie
vous même à demander des contreparties
comme je vous conte n'est pas un mode
pour repartir dans un premier temps
c'est allez-y vous avez besoin que vous
créez de l'arrêt de la richesse et bien
se reposer quand allez vous accepter de
regarder la réalité en face ça fait déjà
depuis dans le quinquennat précédent on
a fait le cic aulas et on a dit vous
allez voir les entreprises on va faire
un grand appel pour que l aile en bouche
elles ne l'ont pas fait là vous me dire
ben non mais faut vraiment qu'ils se
prennent par la main olala excuses s'il
vous plaît faites des efforts ok ils ne
le font pas ça fait qu'on le voit sauf
dans quelques quelques secteurs
spécifiques mais où on est tellement
loin en termes de salaires et de
conditions de travail que
conférant des entreprises une conférence
salariale annuelle avec une augmentation
du smic cela peut créer une conférence
salariale annuelle c'est une c'est une
revendication à une proposition qui
depuis bien avant valérie pécresse avait
été portée notamment par benoît hamon
2017 et par d'autres donc voilà la
question des salaires doit revenir
effectivement au coeur mais l'action
publique elle doit et le gouvernement
l'état doit prendre sa part à la fois
parce qu'il à l'outil du smic est à la
fois parce qu'il à l'outil de la
conditionnalité des aides aux
entreprises vous dites prenez-vous par
la main etc on a vous avez baissé
drastiquement 10 milliards par an les
impôts sur les sur des impôts de
production 9e solo de poursuivi la
baisse de l'impôt sur les sociétés il y
a une manne gigantesque de fonds publics
qui ont été destinés à aider les
entreprises donc ce sont des contrôles
sans attendre et non pas attendre qu'ils
le fassent de leur propre chef il faut
conditionner l'intégralité des aides
d'ailleurs pas coq en terme social et
aussi en termes environnementaux du
sofitel et paulhan j'essaye 1-2
d'interpréter c'est que macron
finalement est toujours le président des
riches il a pas changé alors on va vous
je crois qu'on va parler un brûle un peu
du pouvoir d'achat tout à l'heure doit
être un sujet aussi en cours on voit
bien que quand on parle de pouvoir
d'achat devrait il faut se méfier parce
que pour la chasse et au beaucoup de
ressenti aussi mais les certitudes ou
les chiffres factuel qu'on peut donner
c'est quand même des baisses d'impôts
pour les entreprises oui pour les pour
toute personne oui aussi et de façon
très importante taxe d'habitation dieu
sait qu'on en a parlé sur ses plateaux
et c'est une évidence aujourd'hui c'est
une réalité
augmentation du juge troupes une vo ça y
est je les ai perdus de la prime
d'activité excusez-moi colossal pour une
personne qui est au smic aujourd'hui
avec toutes ces aides on arrive à un 13e
mois et demi c'est un battle rsa se sert
de résidence urbain est-ce que vous avez
vous parlé du président des riches c'est
vous qui me parlait des prisons dirigées
dit que non on a consisté votre kiosque
après c'est votre question et donc je
vous réponds que président des riches
qui s'occupe en particulier des gens qui
sont au smic et à petit revenu voir un
smic 2003 à 2004 c'est pas le président
des riches sur trente secondes sur cette
réforme de l'assurance chômage est ce
que vous admettez cure a sans doute des
perdants
je voudrais que dans les perdants il y
est toutes les entreprises qui ont joué
avec les cdd ça a commencé avec le bonus
malus et je voudrais que ça continue et
que les perdants ce soit ceux qui ont
joué avec les cdd pour mettre en
précarité des gens qui ne méritent pas
ça 14h44 sur public sénat dans 15
minutes les questions d'actualité a
toujours de la parole de suivre les
questions d'actualité vont débuter on va
de suite retrouvé jean mas siégeant vous
allez suivre la séance avec votre
communauté dans quelques instants
et oui absolument steve on va suivre
cette séance ensemble avec avec le chat
ici sur tweets chiha deux sujets qui
intéressent beaucoup les internautes ce
fameux rapport sauvé sur la paie de
crime de la pédocriminalité au sein de
l'église catholique la question de son
caractère systémique et puis cette
phrase polémique qui a été prononcée
dans un autre média ce matin comme quoi
le secret de la confession serait plus
important que les lois de la république
évidemment ça fait penser au séparatisme
ça fait penser à beaucoup de choses ça
interpelle énormément les internautes se
serait peut-être du coup l'occasion cet
après-midi d'avoir une question
gouvernement de la part des sénateurs et
sénatrices
sur ce sujet l'autre sujet qui intéresse
de plus en plus les internautes en ce
moment c'est la question diplomatique il
ya plusieurs sujets en ce moment qui qui
nous sautent au visage si je puis dire
il ya la question de la pêche entre la
france et le royaume uni le royaume uni
qui ne jouent pas le jeu des accords qui
ont été signés les pêcheurs français qui
les précèdent les pêcheurs français qui
râlent ils ont bien raison de le faire
donc l'appareil une question au
gouvernement qui pourrait être
intéressante la crise diplomatique avec
l'algérie visiblement le gouvernement
algérien emma une fin de non-recevoir à
emmanuel macron que va répondre jean
yves le drian on voudrait bien
l'entendre cet après midi sur ce sujet
et puis sur la question du de la
géopolitique et emmanuel macron a eu au
téléphone semble-t-il anthony blinken le
secrétaire d'état américain qu'est ce
qu'ils se sont dit où en sont les
relations franco américaines ou en lots
temps où on est l'union européenne bref
tu le vois steve beaucoup de questions
qui se posent cette après midi beaucoup
d'attentes dans votre communauté genre à
tout à l'heure pour revenir cette
question du pouvoir d'achat se fait
tailler polian malgré la crise le
pouvoir d'achat sous macron a augmenté
c'est en fait c'est les chiffres
viennent de l'insee +0 4% en 2020
oui mais en fait après on peut toujours
travailler sur des moyennes qui conte
qui concerne tout le monde
ça écrase tout on comprend pas ce qui se
passe si la situation était aussi
formidable si effectivement on avait
tant lutté contre le chômage et est le
président de tous et toutes etc on
observerait pas dans ce pays aujourd'hui
une colère aussi aussi profonde et qui
pour ma part m'inquiète c'est qu'on
n'est pas là dans un quelque chose à
observer et puis ce serait juste
récréatif amusant non ça ne l'est pas du
tout c'est très inquiétant aujourd'hui
les 20 % des français les plus les plus
pauvres pendant cette crise ils ont d
épargne et vous savez on parle beaucoup
de gens de le de l'épargné en france qui
a beaucoup augmenté et il ya des
dizaines de milliards d'euros qui ont
été récoltés par départ de france est un
peu plus d'une centaine
mais il ya aussi 20% des français les
plus en difficulté qui eux soit se sont
endettés soit ont un petit bas de laine
qui a encore réduit
donc on peut considérer après qu'il y a
eu et nous l'avons soutenu par exemple
via le chômage partiel une protection
des salariés mais nous considérons ces
nous observons qu'il y a tout un pan de
la population les plus précaires les
étudiants qui eux en fait ont vécu tout
cela de plein fouet n'ont pas été
forcément protégé par le quoi qu'il en
coûte parce que le quoi qu'il en coûte
n'a pas été universel et eux ont subi
une dégradation très profonde de leurs
de leur situation sinon on ne verrait
pas
comment dirais-je l'aide alimentaire qui
continuent à avoir une augmentation très
très forte de du nombre de personnes qui
ont recours donc je crois que il faut il
faut vraiment avoir avoir cela en tête
pour bien apprécier la situation et
comprendre ce qui se passe dans notre
pays aujourd'hui oui peut-être ce
chiffre de 0.4 vous vous tenez je n'en
doute pas mais que cast il derrière en
termes d inégalités c'est l'inégalité
qui elles n'ont cessé de grandir on va
tout de suite retrouvé quentin qu'elle
met en selle des conférences quentin
vous êtes avec jean-françois il son
rapporteur général les républicains du
budget pour l'année prochaine j'imagine
qu'il a suivi de près les manifestations
d'hier sur le pouvoir d'achat est
exactement steve bonjour monsieur sont
un bon jour ces mobilisations qui
avaient lieu hier on se souvient que
vous un an avant le la crise des gilet
jaune vous aviez au gouvernement de se
méfier sur la hausse notamment des taxes
sur les essences sur l'un sur l'essence
devient peut alerter avant l'heure sur
un mouvement d gilet jaune est ce que
vous aviez qu'on est dans le même moment
aujourd'hui avec une crise autour du
pouvoir d'achat des français il ya un
sujet pouvoir d'achat mais on n'est pas
dans le même la même difficulté en terme
de crise la crise des gilet jaune elle
était quasiment la réplique tectonique
de la volonté du gouvernement d'imposer
une hausse vertigineuse de la taxe
carbone là c'est finalement si plus un
phénomène mondial des distributeurs des
pays producteurs
forcément et notamment d'une indexation
autour du gaz une inflation depuis le
début de l'année finalement qui
échappent complètement aux capacités des
états et finalement on a l'impression
que l'état aujourd'hui est l'état
français mais comme d'autres mais l'état
français est important incapable de
bouger
pour redonner de la souplesse est
finalement desserrer cette espèce de
mâchoire qui enferme les français autour
des questions énergétiques mais on
parlait de cette hausse du pouvoir
d'achat qui est mesuré par l'insee on en
parlait sur le plateau de style jourdain
lots du ressenti des français qui est
tout autre qu'ils ont l'impression que
le pouvoir d'achat a baissé comment est
ce que vous comprenez cette
contradiction la contradiction elle
n'est pas aussi contradictoires que ça
elle est tout simple quand vous déversé
des milliards d'euros du jour au
lendemain on expliquait hier qu'on
n'avait pas un ou deux millions d'euros
pour tel ou tel territoire et là il ya
une avalanche de deux milliards d'euros
qui sont déversées sur tous les
territoires et regardez on a une annonce
qui a fait une présentation du plf qui
est du projet de lacie lance donc du
budget de l'année prochaine qui est
incomplète ou nous parle pas de grand
plan d'investissements ou non par mon
revenu d'engagement alors on sait pas si
il est mort né en tous les cas il n'est
pas mort mais il n'est pas né non plus
et aujourd'hui voilà que pensait
justement c'est la suite de votre
déclaration mais ma question suivante
c'est que penser de jean castex qui veut
par amendement venir potentiellement
alors je vais vous dire pour moi c'est
une vaste plaisanterie c'est un peu
qu'astérix savez ils sont beaux grilles
énergétiques
mais en fait il me propose rien il se
moque des français puisque il en train
de dire que les français paieront
l'addition à l'euro près dire que
peut-être un peu moins aujourd'hui mais
ça durera plus longtemps non honnêtement
c'est pas acceptable c'est pas une
manière de gouverner et quand le pré
ministres derrière sa ville a sorti son
premier bouclier puis il a deuxième où
il dit j'ai peut-être peut-être prendre
encore un uppercut derrière il en train
de dire finalement peut-être combien
sera les taxes bas qui commence par
baisser les taxes aujourd'hui merci
merci jean françois husson on entend que
ces débats autour de la loi de finances
est bien s'annonce musclé ici au sénat
steve en effet merci beaucoup quant à
martin d'evry et je voulais c'est
répondre à votre collègue monsieur son
il parlait déjà du budget 2022 qui est
accusé d'être insincères qu'est ce que
vous lui répondez à jean-françois
mission je réponds deux choses sur la
nationalité je lui rappelle que sincère
c'est à dire qu'ils ont sont
sous-évaluées je lui rappelle que c'est
depuis l'élection d' emmanuel macron que
les tous les budgets sont jugés sincères
c'est nouveau souvenez vous qu avancent
ils étaient en règle générale ah ça
c'est en particulier le dernier et
l'avant dernier sous françois landreau
aussi ça je m'en souviens très bien je
venais d'être élu ensuite que deux
contres contre vérité dit-il je vais y
arriver dans les mois la queue de
contrevérités il vit on déverse des
millions pour l'investissement dans
l'eau dans nos territoires qui sont
toujours les siens alors quels sont les
territoires de la france par les siens
et en même temps il n'y a aucun
investissements faits par le
gouvernement alors je sais pas d'où
vient l'argent ce n'est pas de la
médecine parce que justement c'est un
plan d'investissement qui est
décentralisée pour que les territoires
s'en empare mais c'est bien de
l'investissement et c'est une logique
d'investissement
donc voilà ma deuxième réponse après sur
l'énergie nous sommes tous d'accord il
ya une augmentation colossale de
l'énergie s'est pas dire électricité gaz
électricité c'est pas et puis pétrole
comptablement c'est c'est pas du fait de
la france la france est cliente je le
rappelle quand on est client il ya un
prix qu'on vous impose et vous êtes
obligé de le prendre tel qu'il est alors
on peut discuter des taxes l'idée du
bout lier me paraît beaucoup plus
intéressante au même titre qu'on a fait
ils ont par exemple aujourd'hui bon
alors il faut baisser les taxes et le
gentiment fine d'algoé un algo elle veut
le 110 km elle veut plus de voitures
dans paris elle veut maintenant faire la
gratuité de l'essence donc il ya un
moment il faut qu'elle soit cohérente
elle aussi avec un mini amant il faut il
faut une logique de cohérence et quand
on dit on baisse les taxes on dit dans
ces cas là que l'état a moins d'argent
il faut le dire aussi clairement donc il
va prendre l'argent ailleurs je rappelle
que l'état est déficitaire et pas du
fait d' emmanuel macron ça fait 40 ans
n'ont ainsi si vous enlevez la pandémie
fiscale si je finis si vous enlevez la
pandémie si vous enlevez la pandémie
donc 2017 2018 2019 c'est bien le
gouvernement des menus mais a conquis à
baisser le déficit qui nous a permis de
rentrer dans les critères de maastricht
je vous le rappelle c'est le seul fait
d'avoir ou même des halles en pleine
forme et en pleine santé mais il va
pourtant la pandémie au mieux il va
beaucoup mieux qu'il n'a jamais été
visiblement tout doucement vers
l'hémicycle sofitel et polluant jean
castex promet donc d'agir sur le levier
fiscal si les cours de gaz ne baisse pas
d'ici au printemps à ce que c'est une
bonne mesure selon vous écoutez bonne
mesure où pas moi je pense qu'il faut
effectivement une aide pour les ménages
en difficulté mais que de temps perdu
parce que c'est une grande politique de
réduction de l'utilisation de l'énergie
qui aurait dû être menée et ça n'a pas
été le cas on n'a pas été en termes de
structuration d'une filière pour la
rénovation énergétique au niveau là dans
le budget de relance y alla pleurer
notre autre fois il ya la prime renner
en plus mais il ya la prime rénove mais
il y a elle souffre de nombreuses
insuffisances d'abord ya pas assez de
crédit et puis aussi à des difficultés
pour les ménages modestes pour y accéder
donc en fait c'est une politique
d'ampleur qu'il faut qu'il faut mettre
en place près sur la question du
nucléaire nous avons une position
extrêmement claire qui est de dire que
les grands investissements de demain ne
doivent pas et sur le nucléaire mais il
est évident que
les tous fermés le plus vite possible
comme l'allemagne gardien charbon tu
excusez moi le monde l'énergie en france
est très fort alors les ronces et se dit
mais s'effondre à s'annoncer pas presque
pas pousser très belle énergie à ce que
je disais je ne savais pas ce que je
disais donc
mais non
doivent être sur les énergies
renouvelables mais juste sur cet
amendement seul amendement sera déposé
dans le budget 2022 pour abaisser les
taxes spécifiques qui pèse sur le prix
du gaz ainsi ce qu'a annoncé jean castex
hier ce que vous allez le voter vous cet
amendement non mais attendez il faut
attendre moi je vote pas les amendements
sans savoir ce qu'attendent donc je
verrai je vais je vais attendre de voir
ce qu'il ya dedans
alain sincérité du budget en tout cas le
président le premier président de la
cour des comptes il l'a qualifiée d' un
complet sert qu'on nous présente un
budget et on nous dit améliora tête 2
milliard en plus pour les jeunes mais
peut-être pas puis on va peut-être 30
milliards pour l'investissement mais
peut-être pas donc on vous présente un
budget avec des équilibres des
maternelles mais peut-être pas donc il
est peut-être il était de sincère dans
son incomplétude enfin ce conflit
il est sincère la complétude il
des chiffres dans l'équation dont je
vois les choses et qui est accompli mais
je compte bien avec ce qu'ils le soient
au fur et à mesure comme en cas
d'une pandémie son départ consorts qu'on
est toujours
une prochaine fois il est 14h 55 les
questions d'actualité vont débuter dans
5 minutes très précisément va tout de
suite retrouvé quentin qu'elle mais
quentin qui est en salle des conférences
avec le sénateur socialiste bernard
jomier qui est en faveur de la
vaccination obligatoire exactement il
est en faveur de la vaccination
obligatoire et son groupe bonjour
monsieur daumier votre groupe le groupe
socialiste va présenter une proposition
de loi qui sera débattu en séance le 3
octobre qui est examiné ce matin en
commission des affaires sociales le but
de ce texte est bien c'est une
vaccination obligatoire alors tout
d'abord un mot sur la façon dont ça
fonctionnerait dans votre esprit dans
l'esprit cette proposition de loi
comment rendre obligatoire cette
vaccination au contrôle que 8,19
c'est très simple on modifie la loi
actuellement le code de santé publique
prévoit qu'ils aient 11 vaccins
obligatoires donc là on en ajoute un 12e
et puis après c'est le gouvernement qui
par voie règlementaire décide des
modalités c'est à dire le calendrier de
mise en oeuvre quelle sont les tranches
d'âge concernée est ce que c'est
certaines tranches d'âge c'est ce que
c'est tout le monde nous le législateur
l'idée c'est de fixer le principe et
après de laisser au gouvernement la
latitude pour l'appliquer au mieux alors
continuons sur l'idée de ce principe on
voit que l'épidémie elle recule
aujourd'hui on peut le dire au moins en
métropole pourquoi alors vouloir
relancer un débat avec une épidémie qui
régresse parce qu'on arrive à un moment
où vous voyez un pourcentage important
de la population qui est vacciné
quasiment 75 % mais que c'est
insuffisant pour nous permettre de
basculer on va dire dans une épidémie
qui viendra un bruit de fond et donc
comment est ce qu'on gagne les quelques
points de vaccination qui nous manque
bien sûr il ya les verts ne s'est fait à
l'heure actuelle est-ce que ça produit
c'est que on est à trente mille nouveaux
axes signer par jour donc si on continue
à ce rythme là et bien là protection va
l'atteindre en juillet 2022 donc il faut
accélérer il faut trouver nouveaux
moyens et c'est pour ça que cet outil
qui a démontré dans d'autres situations
qu'il est efficace on le propose vous
disiez aux accents obligatoire
aujourd'hui ils sont contrôlés
globalement à la crèche à l'école
comment est-ce qu'on contrôlait ce
douzième vaccin qui sera obligatoire
alors il faut pas il faut pas
survalorisé la question du contrôle et
de la sanction vous savez les élus de
nouvelle calédonie ont décidé d'une
obligation vaccinale pour toute la
population qui est effective depuis le 3
septembre et qu'est ce qui s'est passé
quand vous regardez les courbes de
vaccination en nouvelle calédonie ghoul
a comparé par exemple aux antilles où
elle était assez par allen est bien là
on nouvelle vague qu'elle est de nice a
grimpé en flèche et pourtant il n'y a
pas de sanction pour le moment il n'y a
pas de contrôle il y en aura peut-être
l'année prochaine mais les élus ont
décidé du principe ils ont voté ils ont
dit rendez vous dans deux trois mois et
on verra si on adopte des comptes les
des sanctions on comprend en fait la
proposition de loi elle est davantage
sur la question du principe que
l'effectivité par exemple dans votre
rapport vous parlez la mise en place
d'un passeport vaccinale pour accéder à
certains lieux vous ne précisez pas
lesquels c'est parce qu'en fait il n'y a
pas vraiment d'effectivité de cette
mesure c'est plutôt d'envoyer un signal
à l'opinion non c'est une mesure qui est
efficace et comme la nouvelle calédonie
vient de le démontrer comme la
vaccination des enfants l'a démontré sa
a provoqué une hausse mais il faut
derrière effectivement qui est des
contrôles nous ce que qu'on propose
c'est la fin du pass sanitaires ça doit
on est terminé du bas sanitaire qui
n'est plus efficace qui a fonctionné
mais qui ne produit plus vraiment
d'effet est par contre oui quand voudra
aller dans un grand événement dans une
salle où il ya 3000 personnes en milieu
clos et bien sûr ce sera normal de
contrôler la vaccination à ce moment là
alors on va leur dire votre texte est
examiné ce matin en commission c'est à
dire avant l'examen en séance il a été
rejeté par la majorité de la droite et
du centre vous regrettez cette position
ici majoritaires au sénat écoutez chacun
prend ses responsabilités moi j'attends
de voir ce que la majorité sénatoriale
dont les votes ont été divers malgré
tout puisqu'une majorité la rejeter mais
certains élus ont voté pour ou se sont
abstenus ce qui montre qu'il ya un débat
sur tous les bancs que la réponse n'est
pas simple et vous savez dans la vie
politique et qu'on s'occupe des français
c'est pas une mesure où ou rien il faut
dire ce qu'on fait sinon si
l'alternative ceux de compte il continué
le pass sanitaire jusqu'en juillet 2022
même avec une clause de revoyure au mois
de février moi je crains que ce soit
inefficace pour arrêter une vague
hivernale donc en face je n'ai pas
entendu proposition merlin juillet vous
êtes la cible de beaucoup d' attaques
sur les réseaux sociaux depuis vous fait
cette proposition comment est ce que
vous expliquez cette hystérisation du
débat public autour des vaccinations
vous savez l'extrême droite parce que
c'est l'extrême droite dont il s'agit a
décidé de s'emparer du vaccin comme d'un
symbole de lutte
contre les autorités sanitaires contre
les autorités politiques au fond contre
notre démocratie et la lutte contre
l'extrême droite c'est tout merci merci
20 janvier je rappelle que cette
pollution doit s'ammener en séance le 13
octobre on verra s'il est bien il ya un
sort différent et de la commission on va
retourner et bien dans l'hémicycle en
tribune de presse retrouver jérôme
rapier bonjour jérôme dites-nous tout du
programme s'il vous plaît un programme
riche quand un programme varié avec de
nombreuses questions d'actualité un
aborder cet après midi est un sujet pour
lequel il y aura trois questions de
sénateurs et sénatrices ce sont les
révélations des pandora paper sein sur
un système d'évasion fiscale à grande
échelle on va aussi évoquer notamment l'
influence étrangère dans les universités
au lendemain de la remise d'un rapport
de la mission d'information sénatoriale
sur la stratégie agressive de la chine
qui tente d'influencer
l'université française on va aussi
évoquer les prix de l'énergie avec une
question de maryse carrère et ça démarre
tout de suite
[Musique]
été distribués
nous n'avons pas aussi d'observation
il y en a t'il en séance
je n'en vois poids le procès verbal et à
adopter sous les réserves d'usagé
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement notre séance
et retransmise en direct sur public
sénat sur notre site internet chacun
veillera à respecter le temps et le
respect des uns et des autres
la parole est ta notre collègue maryse
carrère pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre gace
électricité carburant depuis plusieurs
mois les français font face à des
hausses importantes des prix qui met en
difficulté les plus modestes al'approche
de l'hiver c'est augmentation s'ajoute
aux conséquences économiques et sociales
de la crise sanitaire qui ont frappé en
premier lieu les plus fragiles les
chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes depuis le
début de l'année le montant mensuel du
tarif réglementé du gaz a augmenté de
58%
les tarifs réglementés de l'électricité
devraient bondir de 12% en début d'année
le prix du sans plomb 95 a retrouvé son
niveau d'octobre 2010 8 juste avant la
crise des gilet jaune certes des
éléments conjoncturels liés à la reprise
économique mondiale explique ces
tensions sur les prix avec une demande
en forte hausse les facteurs de
formation des prix avec le poids des
taxes accentue également l'élasticité
des tarifs la situation illustre aussi
la difficulté de l'union européenne à
mettre en place dans ce contexte de
transition écologique une stratégie
énergétique commune profitable aux
citoyens européens alors que les
intérêts des états membres sont souvent
divergents néanmoins par delà ces
questions d'urgence demeure pour nos
concitoyens vous avez annoncé la mise en
place d'un bouclier tarifaire pour
contenir d'ici le printemps 2020 2 la
hausse des prix du gaz et de
l'électricité
vous envisagez également de relever aux
besoins de chaque énergie si ces
décisions sont un premier pas que nous
saluons elle reste ponctuelle elles ne
suffiront pas en cas d'hiver rigoureux
ou de nouveaux chocs d'offre ou de
demandes plus largement c'est bien notre
souveraineté énergétique qui est en jeu
la seule à même grâce à notre mix de
garantir que l'énergie reste un bien
commun accessible comment comptez-vous
donc agir pour que l'énergie pour que
l'énergie ne devienne pas à long terme
un facteur d'inégalité qui grèverait le
pouvoir d'achat des français je remercie
l'homme bérengère
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice car effectivement tout d'abord
permettez moi de m'excuser barbara
pompili qui s'adresse à votre question
et qui est actuellement au conseil des
ministres au luxembourg avec donc
effectivement ces prix de l'énergie qui
sont en hausse en forte hausse et ses
réponses qui était nécessaire cette
hausse elle découle vous le savez du
l'augmentation du prix du gaz liées
elles mêmes à l'accroissement de la
demande suscitée par la reprise mondiale
ainsi qu'à une réduction de certaines
productions notamment en russie et en
norvège face à cette situation qui est
largement due à des facteurs extérieurs
il nous fallait qu effectivement des
réponses des réponses pour les ménages
avec d'abord une aide sociale
supplémentaire de 100 euros en faveur
des quelques six millions de foyers
français qui bénéficient déjà du chèque
énergie cette aide supplémentaire elle
sera versée avant la fin de l'année
directement et sans entreprendre de
démarches particulières elle arrivera
dans les boîtes aux lettres des français
et elle s'ajoute évidemment ou chèque
énergie de l'année 2022 qui seront
versés en mars et puis comme le premier
ministre l'a annoncé nous allons
déployer ce bouclier tarifaire qui vise
à protéger tous les français les prix du
gaz seront bloqués tout l'hiver à leur
niveau d'octobre et sans cela la facture
des français aurait pu augmenter de 30%
s'agissant l'électricité l'augmentation
des tarifs règlementés sera au maximum
de 4 % par rapport à 2021 soit environ 5
euros par mois pour un ménage français
qui se chauffent à l'électricité et nous
proposerons dons quant au plf au
parlement d'ajuster la tei cf la taxe
intérieure sur la consommation finale
d'électricité pour atteindre cet
objectif de 4% s'agissant du gaz quand
les prix baisseront sans doute au
printemps nous diminuerons un peu plus
lentement les tarifs afin de revenir à
la normale vous le constatez donc il
s'agit d'un lissage à la montée comme à
la descente pour amoindrir ses effets
pour les pour les ménages français avec
donc des recettes exceptionnelles qui
nous permettent de financer ces hausses
de taxes avec pour l'électricité des
recettes exceptionnelles liées à la
hausse des coûts qui nous permettent
aujourd'hui de financer ces baisses je
remercie où les quelques secondes
maintenant le collègue raymond procès
bon sur le groupe écologie solidarité et
territoires
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'emploi le 30 septembre sans attente
que le conseil d'état n'est rendu son
jugement sur le fond sortait le décret
d'application de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage le conseil d'état
avait pourtant suspendu la réforme
considérant que son application
constituait une erreur manifeste de
jugement eu égard à la conjoncture
économique vous répondrez que les
critères de retour à la bonne fortune à
bonne fortune sont désormais remplies et
permettent aux demandeurs d'emploi de
privilégier les emplois stables et non
les parcours d'emploi fractionné qui
privilégiait selon vous du fait d'une
allocation 30 généreuse sur vos deux
critères de retour à bon on peut à bonne
fortune 1 pouvez vous alors nous
indiquer quelle part dans beauchamp
contrat de plus de 4 voire plus de six
mois période désormais requise pour
l'indemnisation combien au cdi alors que
de multiples lois ont favorisé le
recours aux contrats précaires
2 quant à la baisse des chômeurs de
catégorie a encore faudrait-il compléter
ce critère avec l'évolution à la hausse
des catégories b et c où se trouvent les
salariés qui seront les plus impactés
par votre réforme et la catégorie d où
atterrissent les contrat de sécurisation
professionnelle
suite au licenciement économique
comme beaucoup de jeux du dispositif un
jeune une solution madame la ministre
quelle pertinence quel robustesse de vos
critères de retour à bonne fortune en
regard de votre salle justification de
la réforme favoriser l'emploi durable
mais qui désormais hui qu périssent les
salariés opa cours d'emploi fractionné
pour vous répondre la parole comme un
homme elisabeth bornes ministre du
travail de l'emploi et de l'insertion
vous avez la parole le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice pensée mange alors je vous
confirme que la réforme de l'assurance
chômage est désormais pleinement en
vigueur depuis le 1er octobre en
particulier un nouveau mode de calcul de
l'allocation chômage
s'applique mais uniquement aux
demandeurs d'emploi inscrits depuis
cette date alors en effet nous pensons
que la situation économique et que la
situation du marché du travail justifie
pleinement la mise en oeuvre de cette
réforme de l'assurance-chômage savez que
nous avons eu par exemple 2,4 millions
dhs embauches sur les trois derniers
mois ce qui est un record historique
depuis au moins 15 ans je rappelle par
ailleurs qu'on a 320 mille demandeurs
d'emploi de catégorie a de moins et
qu'on a créé 415 mille emplois depuis le
début de l'année là où on nous prédisait
230000 destructions d'emplois donc je
pense qu'effectivement le contexte est
favorable mais je voudrais aussi revenir
sur cette question de la précarité des
emplois vous mentionnez pour rappeler
que précisément l'un des objectifs de la
réforme et de rues de lutter contre le
recours excessif aux contrats courts
avec le système de bonus malus qui
doivent conduire les entreprises à
proposer des contrats de travail plus
long mais par ailleurs nous voulons
aussi encourager ceux qui le peuvent à
travailler davantage et c'est le sens du
nouveau mode de calcul de l'allocation
chômage alors les clause de retour à
meilleure fortune devrait effectivement
jouer d'ici la fin de l'année 1 je
rappelle que ces clauses elles sont
fondées à la fois sur le nombre
d'embauchés sur le nombre d'embauchés en
contrats de plus d'un mois et par
ailleurs sur la baisse des demandeurs
d'emploi de catégorie a donc les
demandeurs d'emploi sans aucune activité
7 ces indicateurs nous ne les avons pas
inventée pour cette occasion ce sont les
indicateurs qui sont suivies
historiquement par la statistique
publique notamment les déclarations
d'embauché et je pense qu'ils sont
effectivement représentative de la
situation du marché du travail en tout
cas je pense qu'on nous aurait reproché
d' inventer un indicateur ad-hoc pour
mettre en oeuvre ces clause de retour à
meilleure fortune jour merci
madame un songe
merci madame la ministre mais justement
vous ne répondez pas mes questions
puisque la catégorie à certes baisse
mais les catégories b et c sont
actuellement à 2 millions 178/1000 200
demandeurs d'emploi la catégorie des a
augmenté comme jamais effectivement
c'est le réceptacle des plus des
suppressions d'emplois et des ps qui ont
lieu actuellement en conclusion je crois
que plus tôt cette réforme poussera les
demandeurs d'emploi a accepté des
contrats courts très court parce qu'ils
seront paupérisée
merci
donne ma parole notre collègue vanina
paolig agen pour le groupe les
indépendants publique et territoire de
la parole
merci merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre taxonomie verte taxonomie
écologique classification verte quel que
soit son nom pour leur énergie nucléaire
n'en fait pas partie à ce jour alors que
se négocie au niveau européen les seuils
d'émissions de co2 de certaines
activités économiques qui rentreront
dans cette classification et
bénéficieront ce faisant de financement
vert et dette européenne notre
questionnement notamment quant aux
investissements s'intensifient à la
proche de la fin de l'année
le nucléaire est une filière historique
mais surtout c'est une filière
d'excellence française elle nous
garantit une part de souveraineté
énergétique dont toute l'europe
bénéficie y compris ceux de nos voisins
qui mettent leur mouchoir sur leur
mauvaise conscience d'importateurs
d'électricité nucléaire
cette énergie a toute sa place dans
notre mix énergétique
même si sa part doit diminuer c'est
pourquoi la mobilisation des capitaux
nécessaires afin de réaliser des
investissements qui le sont tout autant
ne peut être entravée surtout lorsque
les experts ne convergent pas pour
démontrer que cette énergie préjudice
irait à l'atteinte de nos objectifs
ovi environnementaux ou à notre combat
ultra légitime contre les effets du
dérèglement climatique
madame la ministre la neutralité carbone
en 2050 ne pourra pas se faire sans
cette technologie bas carbone y
consacrer des moyens suffisants revient
à financer la recherche pour maintenir
sur l'existant des unités toujours plus
fiables et plus efficaces enfin cela
signifie surtout se mettre en capacité
d'accroître la sûreté des sites et de
mieux garantir leur longévité les enjeux
économiques et industriels sont immenses
pour notre pays je prends pour exemple
la centrale de nogent-sur-seine dans
l'aube prolonger son activité dans les
meilleures conditions assure de garder
un haut niveau d'expertisé une
verticalité nécessaire dans tous les
métiers sur site
est sécurisé aussi l'évolution de notre
mix énergétique
madame la mini le temps presse et je
sais le gouvernement investit pouvez
vous nous donner l'état des discussions
après leur groupe d'hier et les
positions que la france va défendre dans
les prochains mois je vous remercie
bon vous répondent la parole et à madame
la ministre déléguée en charge de
l'industrie madame manière une échelle
d'aller là par la ministre merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs met à table la
sénatrice vanina paolig agen merci de
rappeler le caractère absolument
stratégique de l'énergie nucléaire dans
notre mix énergétique stratégique car
vous l'avez très bien dit c'est une
énergie indispensable pour décarbonés
notre économie stratégique parce que
c'est une énergie qui est toujours
disponible à un moment où nos besoins en
électricité vont augmenter massivement
stratégique enfin parce qu'elle est
compétitive en termes de prix pour les
particuliers et les entreprises au
moment où le prix de l'électricité
augmentent en europe ce que nous ne voit
pas encore en france il nous voit toute
l'importance de ne pas être dépendante
d'autres pays au d'autres énergies pour
notre mix énergétique alors je veux vous
rassurer madame la sénatrice la position
de la france est absolument sans
ambiguïté sur la taxonomie comme sur les
autres sujets qui touchent à l'énergie
nucléaire
le nucléaire doit figurer dans la
taxonomie c'est le propos que nous
portons barbara pompili bruno le maire
clément bonne et moi même dans tous nos
conseils conseil compétitivité conseil
climat
ecofin et que
le ministre bruno le maire ou encore par
portée en début de semaine de manière
très nette est très précise et c'est
dans cette direction que nous allons
poursuivre les négociations avec fermeté
avec fermeté parce que
les faits sont têtus on ne luttera pas
contre le réchauffement climatique sans
énergie nucléaire ce n'est évidemment
pas contradictoire évidemment pas
contradictoire avec le fait de
développer massivement les énergies
renouvelables notre stratégie sur deux
piliers les énergies nucléaire les
énergies renouvelables jour merci merci
la parole est à notre collègue étienne
blanc pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président
nous mais chez les
messieurs le pré ministre et une mission
d'information sénatoriale vient de
commettre un rapport sur les influences
étrangères extra européennes au sein de
nos universités et du monde académique
français il ressort de ce rapport que
des pays étrangers qui ne sont pas
démocratiques ou qui ne partagent pas
nos valeurs je veux parler de la chine
de la russie ou de la turquie se livrent
aujourd'hui à de véritables ingérence
dans notre monde académique qu'ils
affectent des moyens considérables au
service de leur influence et puis il
ressort aussi de ce rapport qu'en france
les moyens mis à disposition pour
connaître comprendre et lutter contre
ces ingérences ne sont plus aujourd'hui
totalement adapté à l'importance du
phénomène comment par exemple monsieur
près ministre surveiller un institut
confucius hébergés dans une université
car on sait désormais que ces instituts
ne sont pas là que pour enseigner le
chinois ou valoriser la culture chinoise
mais qu'ils se livrent à de véritables
influence dans les universités qui les
hébergent comment par exemple protéger
une communauté scientifique qui
travaille sur la présence des chrétiens
en orient sur le génocide arménien de
1916 alors que l'accès par le
gouvernement turc au territoire turc aux
archives que les berges ce pays ne sont
plus facilité pour cette communauté
scientifique qui parfois même subi des
pressions et des menaces inadmissible
supris ministre l'intégrité scientifique
les libertés académiques sont des
marqueurs essentiel dans nos démocraties
occidentales
ce sont des marqueurs essentiel pour nos
libertés le gouvernement l'entente il de
la sorte et comment entente il mieux les
protéger
pour vous répondre
l'enseignement supérieur et de
l'innovation
merci monsieur le président mesdames
sénatrice messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur blanc je tiens tout
d'abord à saluer comme toujours la très
grande qualité du travail de cette
mission vous présidiez et qui était à
l'initiative du groupe adp et du
rapporteur andré gattolin cette mission
elle touche un sujet majeur vous l'avez
rappelé c'est un sujet qui touche en
réalité notre société dans son ensemble
mais qui appelle un traitement
particulier s'agissant de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche les 26
propositions que vous avez fait
poursuivre en cinq grands objectifs sous
font déjà l'objet d'un travail d'
analyse approfondie et rigoureux de la
part de mes équipes et je tiens à
rappeler comme j'ai pu le faire lors de
mon audition au mois de septembre
qu'effectivement il nous faut absolument
préserver l'intégrité scientifique et
libertés académiques qui sont
indissociables et c'est d'ailleurs tout
l'objet du deuxième objectif de votre
rapport et c'est aussi ce que vous avez
souhaité faire dans le cadre de la loi
de programmation de la recherche qui
contient des avancées majeures en la
matière cet attachement aux libertés
académiques et à l'intégrité
scientifique ne doit pas
muté évidemment les interactions et les
échanges internationaux
mais ceux ci doivent se réaliser sans
naïveté
alors grâce au haut fonctionnaire de
défense et de sécurité grâce à la
mission ministérielle sûreté et
sécurisation de l'enseignement supérieur
et de la recherche grâce aux 160
fonctionnaires de sécurité défense au
réseau coordonné aux dispositifs de
protection du potentiel scientifique et
technique et nous portons un intérêt
tout particulier à la recommandation de
la mission qui vise à l'étendre à
l'ensemble des disciplines
universitaires bien je crois que nous
portons effectivement ensemble ce sujet
et que les conclusions et
recommandations de la mission
d'information du sénat convergent très
largement avec l'action ministère et
plus largement celle de ce gouvernement
en lien avec l'ensemble des
administrations concernées choix merci
monsieur le président de la mission
merci d'avoir salué le travail que nous
on fait avec andré gattolin le sens de
ce rappeur madame la ministre c'est de
dire attention il se passe aujourd'hui
du fait de dd actions d' influence
menées par ces pays qui ne partagent pas
nos valeurs démocratiques
il se passe des phénomènes considérable
contre lesquelles on ne peut pas lutter
avec un sabre de bois donc nous sommes à
disposition pour échanger avec le
gouvernement sur ce sujet
particulièrement grave
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la parole est un autre collègue nathalie
goulet pour le groupe de l'union
centriste donner la parole
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues la
fraude fiscale simple pacte républicain
le nouveau scandale des pandora paper on
est une nouvelle illustration après les
luxes clic panama peppers et tant
d'autres tout va bien dans mon
tranquille puisque 48 heures après ces
révélations l'union européenne supprime
trois territoires de la liste des
territoires non coopératifs trois
paradis fiscaux de moi c'est vrai que
c'est un mauvais timing la france va
présider le conseil européen monsieur le
ministre quel mesure entendez vous
prendre pour lutter contre la fraude et
l'évasion fiscale alors que notre dette
flamber pendant que certains cachent des
millions dans les paradis fiscaux nos
étudiants font la queue devant les
banques alimentaires et nos agriculteurs
se débattant des difficultés infernale
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole et au ministre délégué en charge
des comptes publics je dis stop la
parole
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice nathalie goulet
quelques mots d'abord pour revenir sur
les révélations d'un consortium de
journalistes 600 journalistes 117 pays
concernés et 12 millions de données qui
seraient exploités ou exploitable par ce
consortium des journalistes pour mettre
à jour des pratiques d'optimisation
d'évasion voire de fraude fiscale dans
un angle un grand nombre de pays et par
le biais de sociétés offshore à ce stade
et je vous êtes retraité sur ce point
les informations dont le gouvernement
dispose et à travers le gouvernement la
direction générale des finances
publiques selon les informations
révélées par la presse et comme à chaque
fois que c'est le cas en pareille
circonstance nous avons donné avec bono
maire des instructions extrêmement clair
la direction générale des finances
publiques consistant à exploiter
vérifier et analyser chacune des données
en sa disposition par ces révélations
médiatiques pour d'une part vérifier si
des contribuables français sont
concernés et le cas échéant diligenter
des contrôles fiscaux les plus sévères
qu'ils soient et les cachant aussi en
lien évidemment avec le ministre de la
justice les fonctions les procédures j10
qui s'avérait les plus utiles nous
continuons à oeuvrer contre la tranche
fiscale à la fois à l'échelle française
à l'échelle européenne nous avons créé
permis l'adoption d'une loi de lutte
contre la fraude en octobre 2018 vous
aviez été actif dans ces débats avec la
création d'une politique fiscale nous
avons renforcé notre système
d'information avec notamment la
pérennisation de la rémunération des
aviseurs et nous développons
développement au niveau européen sens
dans lesquelles nous poussons des
échanges d'informations extrêmement
poussée puisque pour 2019 ce sont 7
milliards d'euros de revenus fiscaux
complémentaire à l'échelle de l'union
européenne qui ont été trouvés et dégagé
par des échanges d'informations portant
sur plus de 84 millions de comptes que
nous avons pu ainsi investiguer vérifier
grâce à cette coopération il aurait
beaucoup à dire pour développer les
différents sujets et les différentes
priorités que nous avons ce sont là les
premiers exemples je crois pouvoir
revenir à l'occasion de prochaines
questions sur ce que nous faisons aussi
en matière de lutte contre la fraude
fiscale mais je veux vous assurer de la
détermination la plus totale à lutter
contre cette fraude et à exploiter
l'ensemble des données auxquelles nous
aurons accès par les révélations vous
avez cités madame nathalie goulet ouais
mais c'est le ministre on est toujours
dans l'expo est votre bilan il n'est pas
exactement celui que vous dites parce
que vous avez réduit les moyens humains
pour le contrôle fiscal et douanier vous
avez démontré la délégation nationale à
la lutte contre la fraude vous avez
perdu du temps pour la mise en place du
système de détection précoce de fraude à
la tva qui est un système dna qui était
appliquée par tous les pays européens
dont on vous a demandé depuis plusieurs
années d'essayer de l'appliquer en
france qui vient seulement d'être
appliquée je rappelle que la fraude à la
tva c'est 5 milliards de fraudes
détectées l'année dernière et 10
milliards au niveau de l'europe le
gouvernement s'est opposé à l'amendement
du sénat qui visait à interdire les
aides qu'ovide aux entreprises disposant
de filiales dans les paradis fiscaux
préférant la circulaire allons savoir
pourquoi la circulaire c'est mieux que
la loi vous me le dirait peut-être il
reste 777 enquête préliminaire en cours
qui sont actuellement ouvertes pour des
affaires de fraude fiscale et de
blanchiment vous êtes opposé à la
position légitime du sénat qui a voté la
possibilité de prolongation de ses
enquêtes pour ces faits des liens que
vous vouliez réduire sans distinguo
dents la confiance justice et pour 577
enquête préliminaire il ya trois
enquêteurs je suis pas très sûr que
l'adéquation soit exact les chiffes
pluie un test de ce bilan désastreux le
résultat de la lutte contre la fraude a
été divisé par deux en 2017 et ces
chiffres sont ceux de votre ministère
que vous retrouverez dans l'excellent
bouquin de charles prat qui s'appelle le
cartel des fraudes 2 ou là on parle de
fraude fiscale monsieur le ministre le
plf et arrive et j'espère que nous
pourrons prendre des mesures vraiment
efficace qu est-ce que pour l'instant le
compte n'y est pas
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue éric
bocquet dont le groupe communistes
républicains citoyens écologistes mais
l'ascendant sur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues voici la deuxième lame
ma question s'adresse à monsieur mise
l'économie et des finances mais je sais
que monsieur du souk ne répondra en
février dernier un grand journal du soir
révélait dans le cadre d'une enquête
dénommé open luxe l'existence de 55000
sociétés offshore détenant ensemble
6500 milliards d'euros d'actifs au
luxembourg cette semaine un consortium
un consortium de journalistes publient
une nouvelle enquête les pandora paper
même si la boîte de pandore fut ouverte
il ya très longtemps par laquelle nous
apprenons que 29 mille autres sociétés
offshore viennent d'être mises au jour
créée et gérée par 14 cabinets et
officines spécialisées
monsieur le ministre vous ne le maire
s'est déclaré choqué quand tous nos
citoyens sont ulcérés par ses
révélations incessantes faite par la
presse ces dernières années pour les
milliardaires concernés responsables
politiques de très haut niveau sportif
les trafics en tous genres l'objectif
est d'échapper à l'impôt et aux juges
grâce à cette industrie de l'opacité le
problème est systémique
monsieur ministre comptez vous rester
aux chocs et à la vérification
monsieur du simple ministre délégué en
charge des comptes publics pour répondre
merci à monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs destinataire monsieur le
sénateur ben ok je ne compte pas en
rester au shaq et nous ne comptons pas
en rester aux chocs nous avons gelé d'y
développer des outils de lutte contre la
fraude fiscale il faut rendre à césar ce
qui est à césar le développement des
outils de lutte contre la fraude fiscale
date depuis plusieurs années et lorsque
l'on regarde les quelques années
écoulées on peut citer
on peut citer pardon la loi sapin 2 qui
a été adoptée on peut citer la loi sur
la confiance et la moralisation de la
vie politique en 2014 on peut citer la
loi de 2018 mais aussi la loi confiance
d'août 2010 est à chaque fois les
gouvernements successifs ont travaillé
pour que les administrations sont dotés
d'outils plus performants avec la loi du
23 octobre 2010 la création d'une
politique d'une police fiscale avec les
échanges d'informations que j'évoquais
en réponse à madame la sénatrice goulet
c'est la possibilité je le disais il ya
un instant de dégager au niveau
communautaire plus de 100 milliards
d'euros de revenus supplémentaires par
lutte contre la fraude fiscale vous nous
dites hommes est-ce que vous en restez
au chaud qu'à la vérification nous en
restons avant tout à la vérification et
à chaque fois que nous le pouvons à des
contrôles et 1,10 redressement vous avez
évoqué un certain nombre d'affaires qui
avait été révélé je voudrais revenir sur
l'une d'entre elles la sphère dit panama
peppers pour vous dire que en matière
l'administration fiscale française a
identifié un certain nombre de
contribuables français concernés que
nous avons menées à leur terme 657
dossier soit de régularisation soit de
redressement soit le dossier qui ont
fait l'objet d'une judiciarisation et
cela a permis à l'état français de
recouvrer plus de 200 millions d'euros
de régularisations ou de sanction à la
suite
mais pardonnez moi monsieur le sénateur
assouline mais vous dites onze mille
milliards comme si c'était onze mille
milliard français je vous parle des 657
contribuables français détecté dans
panama peppers vous devrez vous en
féliciter et féliciter l'administration
plutôt que de faire des comparaisons qui
n'ont ni queue ni tête permettez moi de
vous le dire l'essentiel pour moi
c'était que l'administration est au
travail mais que quand elle travaille
cela paye et cela permet de sanctionner
les fraudeurs
monsieur bouquet
et julie ces scandales successifs que se
traduisent à chaque fois par des
milliards en fuite pour la république
nécessite une réaction déterminée nous
sommes constructifs vous le savez et
nous nous permettons de vous suggérer 3
pistes d'actions immédiates première
piste vous pouvez recréer des postes de
contrôleurs dé le projet loi de finances
qui vient au parlement dans quelques
jours pour rappel 38 mille emplois ont
été supprimés depuis 2002 dans les
finances publiques 2 vous pouvez créer
l'observatoire de lutte contre la fraude
fiscale annoncée en 2018 jamais mis en
place nous sommes toujours candidats à
titre bénévole 3 la france va présider
le conseil de l'union européenne à
partir de janvier 2022
l'union européenne a décidé hier de
retirer de la liste des paradis fiscaux
les seychelles effectivement en plein
coeur des révélations du dernier
scandale inscrivait à l'agenda de ce
semestre une mise à jour de cette liste
en y incluant notamment le luxembourg et
chypre
[Applaudissements]
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue michel dennemont pour le voulu
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres
sa collègue ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre chargé des comptes
publics
chez le ministre
le gouvernement s'est engagé tout au
long de la crise pour soutenir les
collectivités locales menacées par la
fragilisation de la budget en 2020 et
2021 les tags son solde se dégrader de
près de 8% maintenant à son compte
l'essentiel du coût de la crise au
contraire les collectivités qui n'ont
pas compté leurs efforts et puis dans
l'ensemble leur budget grâce au soutien
inédit de l'état beaucoup l'ont reconnu
et ont salué cet effort sans précédent
mais certains ont choisi à quelques jeux
d'alimenter la polémique dénonçant une
belle dotation de 50 millions d'euros
qui témoigne aurait selon eux d'un
mépris du gouvernement à leur endroit
une polémique 106 nous fait oublier dans
son éléphant financier de l'état dur
l'actrice alors même que le sujet de
discorde au présenterai au total moins
de 0 2 % du budget des régions et fo
temps le gouvernement à des lycéens
également près des régions il a compensé
leurs pertes de recettes à hauteur de
192 millions sans compter les 600
millions de crédits d'investissement
débloqués dès 2020 pour se tenir le
budget sinistrés c'est dans ce contexte
que nous avons pu lire un étonnement que
les régions et le gouvernement ne semble
pas partager la même vision de la
réalité du pays on comprend mieux ce
slogan qu'on sait que parmi ces
présidents de région pas moins de deux
sur déjà candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
mais on peut douter que de telles
déclarations serbe la clarté et la
sincérité du débat public
monsieur le ministre
pouvez vous nous rappeler l'ensemble des
mesures prises durant la crise pour
soutenir les finances des collectivités
locales et singulièrement celle des
régions de l'hexagone et de l'outre-mer
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur denman d'abord
permettez moi de vous dire le plaisir
que nous avons à vous retrouver dans cet
hémicycle
le plaisir tout simplement de vous
retrouver vous m'interrogez sur l'action
de l'état pour accompagner les
collectivités locales dans la crise et
en particulier les régions job d abord
souligné qu'en matière d'accompagnement
les garanties de recettes que nous avons
apportées par compensation avances
remboursables les aides sectorielles
mais aussi les aides à l'investissement
représente un total de 10 5 milliards
d'euros que l'état a débloqué pour
accompagner les collectivités pour ce
qui concerne les régions ça s'est
traduit par des garanties de recettes
garanties en matière de tva garanties en
matière de thé icpe avec un montant
garanti supérieur à 900 millions d'euros
contre une moyenne annuelle de 350 à 400
millions d'euros et surtout nous avons
garanti aux régions en 2020 et en 2021
le niveau de la cvae hauteur de l'année
2019 soit la plus haute année historique
à hauteur de 75 milliards d'euros pour
les régions d'outre-mer ça s'est aussi
traduit par l'intégration dans ce panier
de ressources garanti les ressources
liées à l'octroi de mer ou à la taxe
spéciale sur la consommation des
carburants ce qui représente un montant
supplémentaire de 80 millions d'euros
nous avons aussi aidé à l'investissement
vous l'avez dit le bloc local mais les
régions aussi pour 600 millions d'euros
et nous allons continuer à les
accompagner d'abord avec l'abondement
des contrats de projets entre l'état
l'état et les régions qui sont en grande
discussion mais aussi dans le cadre de
l'affectation des ressources
traditionnelles puisque les régions de
france vont bénéficier du fait de la
reprise d'une dynamique des recettes
liées à la tva de 780 millions d'euros
pour l'année 2022 ce qui laisse augurer
aussi un redressement tout à fait
singulier important et enfin le premier
ministre s'est récemment engagé devant
le congrès des régions de france a
diminué de 100 millions d'euros les
frais de gestion de la fiscalité locale
ce sont 100 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour les recettes des
régions les régions avaient à la fin de
l'année 2020 un excédent supérieur à 5
milliards d'euros ce qui leur permettait
de faire face à leurs besoins this man
avec les mesures annoncées de protection
d'accompagnement des investissements
d'augmentation des recettes soit par la
dynamique de la tva soit par la baisse
des frais de gestion nous les mettons
capacité de faire face à leurs
engagements et d'accompagner l'état et
les français son chemin de la reprise
et donner la parole à notre collègue
yann chanterelle pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicaine
chez sa première prise de parole dans
notre hémicycle
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président c'est un
honneur de représenter les françaises et
français établis hors de france au sein
de notre assemblée mes chers collègues
il y a un an jour pour jour notre
compatriote emmanuel charpentier
recevait le prix nobel de chimie établis
hors de france depuis 24 ans à le
déclarer alors je cite je pense que la
france aurait du mal à me donner les
moyens que j'ai en allemagne la
recherche scientifique a besoin d'être
soutenue par le gouvernement un an plus
tard le constat est sans appel la
semaine dernière le journal le monde
publié une enquête accablante sur le
déclin de la recherche en france des
moyens en dessous de la moyenne des pays
de l'osce et des oeufs des salaires
indigne des équipements vieillissants et
une dégradation des conditions de
travail qui affecte la productivité de
la recherche française loin de régler
cette situation la lpr voter en 2020
consacre le manque d'ambition du
gouvernement en accroissant la
précarisation des contrats et les
inégalités entre laboratoires en tant
que conseiller consulaire est désormais
sénateur des français de l'étranger j'ai
rencontré des centaines de compatriotes
doctorante et doctorants chercheuses et
chercheurs qui devant ce manque cruel de
moyens ont fait le choix d'exercer leur
métier et de poursuivre leur passion à
washington cambridge belem ou encore à
sydney à l'heure où la planète vit des
bouleversements climatiques et
sanitaires majeurs comment le
gouvernement compte il donnait à la
recherche française les moyens de
répondre à l'urgence de ces défis
[Applaudissements]
je l'enseignement supérieur de la
recherche et de l'innovation
abidal avait la parole
merci président mesdames et sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur des
sénateurs chanterelle permettez moi
aussi de vous féliciter pour votre
élection en tant que sénateur
représentant les français établis hors
de france et je sais que nous aurons
l'occasion de nous revoir dans la
commission culture éducation et
communication du sénat vous avez raison
monsieur le sénateur en réalité
contrairement à ce que titre le monde ça
n'est pas la recherche française qui est
en déclin c'est les financements qui ont
été accordés à la recherche française
pendant les vingt dernières années qui
sont ignobles qui sont
qui n'ont pas permis de pouvoir garder
nos talents et c'est ce gouvernement qui
est en train d'inverser la tendance pour
la première fois nous avons en
candidature sur des doctorants
internationaux une augmentation majeure
du nombre de doctorants ses 25 milliards
d'euros de réinvesti dans la recherche
au travers de la loi pour la recherche
c'est 500 millions d'euros cette année
sur le budget c'est deux fois plus que
les quinquennat précédent c'est ça la
réalité monsieur le sénateur ces 7
milliards d'euros supplémentaires dans
le plan innovation santé pour supporter
le secteur de la santé dont nous avons
vu à quel point ils avaient besoin
d'être encouragé ses 7,8 milliards
d'euros dans le plan de relance sur le
périmètre enseignement supérieur
recherche et innovation et c'est ça qui
nous permet notamment de préserver plus
de 2000 emplois hautement qualifiés dans
la recherche le développement qui aurait
pu manquer à notre pays c'est pour la
première fois des recrutements à plus de
deux smic s'est pour la première fois
une augmentation de 30% des salaires des
doctorants c'est pour la première fois
650 emplois supplémentaires au delà des
départs à la retraite qui sont créés et
c'est pour la première fois des
internationaux qui demandent à revenir
en france qu'ils aient été formés en
france ou ailleurs
ces 180 demandes qui sont arrivés dès
cette année au ministère c'est ça
monsieur le sénateur croire en la
recherche française que chantreuil
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre je constate juste que
votre réponse et n'est vraiment pas à la
hauteur de l'urgence et des défis
climatiques et sanitaires auxquels nous
devons faire face concernant le budget
2022 les augmentations annoncées sont
vraiment très en deçà de ce qui était
prévu dans la loi de programmation
quant aux investissements planifiés à
l'horizon 2030 sont beaucoup trop tardif
pour répondre à ces différentes crises
climatiques et sanitaires qui demande
une réponse immédiate
merci
la parole à notre collègue vincent ce
bois pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
garde des sceaux hier une nouvelle prise
d'otage a eu lieu à la prison de haute
sécurité de condé sur sarthe une des
plus sécurisées de france je tiens à
répéter un détenu a su prendre en otage
deux surveillants avec une arme
artisanale depuis 2013 date de création
nous en sommes déjà la sixième prise
d'otages avec le même protocole en 2019
à la suite d'un attentat terroriste
islamiste et d'une prise d'otages
j'alerte et votre prédécesseur qui me
promettait de moyens supplémentaires
pour les gardiens et m'assurer de cette
détermination à renforcer et à sécuriser
sécurité dans des prisons qu'en est il
en est et deux ans après rien n'a changé
les violences et mépris représente le
quotidien de nos gardiens toujours
autant d'armes artisanales et de
téléphone qui circulent sans que les
agents ne puisse fouiller
systématiquement les détenus les
visiteurs il hier vous êtes déplacé pour
rencontrer les surveillants et vous avez
déclaré à la presse je cite j'ai pu
rencontrer la jeune surveillante elle
est profondément choqué d'avoir vu son
collègue avec un poinçon sous la gorge
avec les psychologues nous allons tout
faire pour aider à passer cette épreuve
difficile j'en conclus que pour vous la
solution c'est le psychologue je
continue vous déclarez j'ai tenu à
rencontrer le personnel pénitencier le
personnel à présenter des difficultés
des revendications nous allons
travailler à toutes ces questions bilan
nos interventions ne servent à rien et
vous découvrez la situation à chaque
événement sans y remédier enfin vous
déclaré je cite toujours que je remercie
les détenus qui particulièrement
responsable parce qu'ils sont restés
dans leurs cellule alors que le preneur
d'otage des avait ouverte la voilà la
vérité vous avez 116 la compassion pour
les détenus plus que pour les gardiens
les victimes je réitère donc ma question
de 2019 quand allez vous permettre au
gardien de pouvoir procéder à des
fouilles systématiques et les équipés de
pistolets à impulsion électrique comme
il vous le demande
pour vous répondre le parent le garde
des sceaux ministre de la justice
monsieur eric dupond moretti merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur s'est joint
immédiatement tiers j'ai tenu à
rencontrer les victimes
pour leur dire
le soutien de mon ministère et le
soutien du gouvernement et de la nation
toute entière j'ai tenu également à
remercier les eris qui sont intervenus
sur place et qui ont permis de dénouer
ce drame j'ai remercié également leur
aide et j'évite parce que c'est vrai
souffrez que je leur dise que des
détenus n'ont pas adhéré à ce que l'un
des leurs a commis ils se sont non
seulement désolidariser mais ils ont
permis la reddition de leurs compagnons
de détention c'est la vérité ensuite
voyez vous je tiens à dire que j'ai
rencontré immédiatement le personnel
tout de suite il était indispensable que
nous ayons un échange je suis allé là
bas avec le directeur de
l'administration pénitentiaire que j'ai
fait nommer et qui est un ancien de la
pénitentiaire et qui s'est naturellement
de quoi il parle alors monsieur le
sénateur on va se dire les choses très
clairement s'agissant des fouilles
systématiques
elles sont prohibés vous devriez le
savoir par la cour européenne des droits
de l'homme notamment dans un arrêt
frérot contre france et nous avons
légiféré en 2019 il y à peu et les
fouilles elles sont parfaitement permise
est autorisé dans certaines conditions
pour le reste je tiens à vous dire qu'un
travail est actuellement en cours en
lien avec les représentants des
personnels pour renforcer la formation
des surveillants c'est une de leurs
attentes s'agissant de budget nous avons
fait ce que vous et paf et je voudrais
dire que dans le budget qui va venir 100
millions d'euros sont consacrés
à la sécurisation des établissements
pénitentiaires 45 millions pour la
sécurisation s'agissant de la lutte anti
drogue dea brouillage des communications
20 millions pour le déplacement pour le
déploiement pardon du système d' alerte
j'ai géré ou localiser le reste
notamment pour les filins le reste
notamment pour la sécurisation des
parkings enfin et j'en termine une
expérimentation sur l'armement des
surveillants pénitentiaires est en cours
notamment à la centrale de condé sur
sarthe pour laquelle je sais vous êtes
mobilisés comme d'ailleurs madame la
sénatrice nathalie goulet qui suit ces
questions depuis bien longtemps je vous
annonce également que le budget 2022 si
vous le voter permettra la création de
600 emplois supplémentaires pour
l'administration pénitentiaire
enfin un dernier mot monsieur le
sénateur le risque zéro n'existe pas et
les personnels que j'ai rencontré en ont
parfaitement conscience mais cela
naturellement ne doit pas nous inviter
au fatalisme il nous invite à l'action
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
avons pris ces mesures
que seulement quelques secondes
[Applaudissements]
comme votre prédécesseur vous réfugier
derrière les droits de l'homme en disant
que vous ne pouvez rien changé et puis
j'imagine
j'imagine que vous allez oublié ce
dossier le redécouvrir la prochaine à la
prochaine tragédie monsieur le ministre
mais si vraiment vous êtes incapable
d'apporter des solutions concrètes pour
quoi nous partager vous pas les méthodes
de sécurité avec le pdg des aéroports de
paris qui lui des assure et heureusement
sinon beaucoup d'avions n'arriverait
certainement pas inclus à sion
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
emilienne poumirol pour le groupe
socialiste écologistes rqge
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur lui fera sans télé solidarité
olivier ferrand les 24 25 et 26
septembre 2021 les sages femmes ont
entrepris un mouvement de grève
dans plus de 150 maternité et dans plus
de 60% des cabinets libéraux une
nouvelle mobilisation aura lieu demain 7
octobre pour la sixième fois cette année
face au manque de reconnaissance aux
contrats précaires aux salaires
insuffisants aux tâches et les
responsabilités de plus en plus élevées
y compris l'accueil des urgences
gynécologiques le manque d'effectifs
permanents ainsi chaque année plus
nombreuses à quitter les maternités pour
se tourner vers l'exercice libéral
ces conditions de travail qui se
détériorent sans cesse mettre à mal la
permanence et la qualité des soins
rappelons que cet été le conseil
national de l'ordre des sages-femmes
tiré la sonnette d'alarmé le manque
d'effectifs dans les maternités ne
permettait plus de garantir la sécurité
des patientes et de nombreuses
maternités ont dû fermer leurs portes le
16 mai septembre monsieur le ministre
vous avez annoncé une revalorisation
financière de 100 euros brut par mois
revalorisation qui est inférieur aux
propositions pourtant formulé par l'igas
dans le cadre d'un rapport qui a été
rendu cet été
mais cette annonce ne traite pas des
causes profondes du mal être des sages
femmes
comment améliorer sa moyenne des moyens
importants la prise en charge des femmes
comment grands de cette profession
attractive ce déficit d'attractivité
sans présidente des maternités et dès
lors un enjeu de santé publique majeur
monsieur le ministre il est urgent d'en
entendre l'inquiétude et la colère des
sages-femmes leurs revendications
dépassent la seule défense de leurs
provisions c'est avant tout les femmes
leur santé physique et mentale et celle
des nouveau-nés que les sages femmes
défendent
pour vous répondre la parole est aux
bilans des shows l'hilarité de la
chanter aussi olivier ferrand vous avez
la parole
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice poumirol merci pour
votre question je pense qu'ici tout le
monde sur tous les bancs est d'accord
pour dire que les sages femmes font un
travail formidable
formidable précieux et qu'elles méritent
la reconnaissance de la représentation
nationale
madame la sénatrice pardonnez-moi à la
mi septembre suite à des travaux d'un
rapport d'inspection générale je n'ai
pas annoncé une revalorisation de 100
euros pour les sages-femmes
hospitalières
la sénatrice c'est une revalorisation
moyenne de 365 euros par mois pour les
sages-femmes hospitalières s'est pas
complètement la même chose
les sages femmes hospitalières grâce aux
ségur et aux annonces complémentaires
percevront percevront 4500 euros net de
plus par an personne ne dit que c'est
trop mais je vous invite à chercher dans
les archives de la république à quand
remonte la dernière revalorisation
équivalente à plus de 4000 euros net par
an pour des salariés du public vous ne
la trouverez pas vous ne trouverez pas
une sage-femme en fin de carrière grâce
aux annonces grâce aux annonces
terminera désormais pas loin des 4000
euros net par mois encore une fois
personne ne dit que c'est trop enfin ne
limitait pas les revalorisations à ce
qu'elles ne sont pas assez pas 100 euros
c'est 360 en moyenne 180 grâce aux ségur
100 euros de prime et encore
l'équivalent de 60 70 euros grâce au
travail sur des grilles indiciaires ça
représente 80 millions d'euros d'efforts
de la nation par an c'est un effort qui
est justifiée qui est tout à fait normal
et auquel il faut aussi rajouter 20
millions d'euros supplémentaires dans le
cas de la convention médicale ou
quasiment 18 millions d'euros en cas de
la convention actuellement à signature
entre les syndicats libéraux et
l'assurance maladie
madame la sénatrice sans aucune
provocation en un an et demi que je suis
ministre ce gouvernement avec le ségur
de santé à augmenter les salaires des
soignants de notre pays autant que les
gouvernements de droite et gauche
successifs depuis plus d'un siècle
réunis
personne ne dit que c'est trop mais dans
le cas du plfss vous le verrez ce sont
10 milliards d'euros de vins de
revalorisation plus j'ajoute raison
demandé une sixième année d'études avec
frédéric vidal nous avons lancé la
mission auprès du ration pour gagner
c'est la sixième année d'études de plus
elle demande un statut médical la
fonction publique hospitalière on leur
accorde le statut médical une filière
médicale dans la fonction publique
hospitalière elles relèveront bien
maintenant les sages-femmes des
directions d'affaires médicale parce que
c'est une profession médicale et votre
question me permet à la fois de remettre
les chiffres là où ils sont et en même
temps de réaffirmer le soutien à cette
profession médicale
certes certes mais si munich j'entends
bien les réformes que vous avez mené les
efforts qui ont été faits très récemment
il n'en demeure pas moins que vous avez
parlé de la réforme des études ou du
statut des sages-femmes et c'est là je
crois le point 2 ou plus important sur
lequel il faut travailler qu est la
principale revendication des sages
femmes mais aussi la parole et notre
collègue catherine belrhiti pour le
groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues le pacte européen pour
l'asile et l'immigration a suscité peu
d'écho médiatique mais le sujet n'en est
pas moins primordiale pour les français
la décision de la commission européenne
d'initier ce pacte est une bonne
nouvelle alors que la pression
migratoire ne fait que s'accentuer
madame la ministre je souhaiterais vous
interroger sur une proposition
importante
bien qu'absente du projet présenté le 23
septembre 2020 le pacte propose
aujourd'hui un filtrage à l'entrée
incluant l'identification de toutes les
personnes qui franchissent sans
autorisation les frontières de l'union
européenne ou qui ont été débarqués
après une opération de sauvetage
cependant cette approche axée uniquement
sur nos frontières risque de rendre
inefficaces ne volonté de traiter et
d'anticiper l'immigration le conseil
européen du 29 juin 2018 étaient
parvenus à s'entendre sur un point
intéressant la création de plateformes
de débarquement en dehors des frontières
de lieux il s'agirait examiner les
demandes d'asile dans des centres gérés
et financés par les pays européens
ces hotspots aurait l'avantagé
d'anticiper le flux est de jouer la
solidarité européenne en répartissant
les demandeurs avant qu'il n'échappe aux
radars des autorités il enverrait un
message clair d'unité européenne et
dissuaderait surtout les passeurs
cette délocalisation a été votée
récemment grâce au soutien de tout
l'échiquier politique par le parlement
du danemark d'autres pays pourraient
suivre cette voie mais un programme
européen aurait beaucoup plus de force
bien sûr il faut convaincre les pays de
départ d'une telle coopération ainsi que
ceux où se situent les principaux points
de passage mais une action coordonnée
des instances européennes et des états
membres constituerait la force
d'entraînement nécessaire madame la
ministre la france va-t-elle s'engager
afin de traduire la composition du
conseil européen de juin 1918 2018
pardon en actes va-t-elle se mobiliser
pour rendre effectif un traitement de
migration qui nous permettent de ne plus
subir les flux et qui évite les drames
humains merci
on vous répondra par les communistes
délégué en charge de la citoyenneté
madame marlène schiappa il avait la
parole
le
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices mais sur les sénateurs madame
la sénatrice nous avons eu longuement le
débat hier après-midi et en soirée et je
remercie les sénatrices et les sénateurs
qui ont pris part à ce débat sur le
paquet européen concernant l'asile et
l'immigration
je vous dire que notre position elle est
très claire nous l'avons des bêtes chez
évoqué longuement hier d'abord vous dire
que notre position c'est dans la droite
ligne de la ligne du président la
république un équilibre très claire
entre l'humanité et la fermeté dire que
le droit d'asile ne doit pas être dévoyé
et c'est le sens des discussions
européennes qui sont en ce moment en
cours je vais vous dire que ces
discussions allaient se poursuivre vous
savez qu'il ya une volonté de cohérence
d'harmonisation des règles pour que
l'ensemble des pays européens qu'ils
soient pays de premières entrée ou pays
comme la france puisse avoir des mêmes
règles dans la confiance mutuelle dans
la cohérence et c'est l'objectif que
nous allons poursuivre dans le cadre de
la présidence française de l'union
européenne nous avons demain matin une
réunion de l'ensemble des ministres de
l'europe en charge la question de
l'asile et l'immigration
justement pour aller plus avant
poursuivre ces négociations et ces
discussions et pour vous répondre que
particulièrement sur la question du
danemark nous avons reçu le débat hier
soir et je vous réponde de nouveau pour
vous dire d'abord que la loi qui a été
votée au danemark 1 n'a pas de valeur
contraignante
et deuxièmement qu'il s'agit d'objectifs
qui sont donnés ce n'est pas à ce stade
la ligne qui est retenue par les
discussions européennes en tout cas qui
est portée par la france dans le cadre
de la présidence française néanmoins sur
la question des contrôles aux frontières
et que vous évoquez vous savez qu'il ya
une volonté de moderniser le système
d'information et notamment de renforcer
les effectifs de frontex pour que nous
puissions attendre dix mille personnes
d'ici l'année 2027 avec des échelons et
c'est la position ambitieuse qui est
portée par la france dans le cas de ces
négociations au niveau européen je vous
remercie
merci la parole à notre collègue
stéphane le 8 pour le groupe de l'union
centriste la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre de la
santé je voudrais revenir sur la
situation des sages femmes qui seront en
grève demain ce n'est pas la première
fois d'ailleurs depuis le début de
l'année depuis janvier ces
professionnels sont déjà descendus
effectivement plusieurs fois dans la rue
pour réclamer plus de reconnaissance que
ce soit par une rosalie revalorisation
salariale on en a parlé ou par une
augmentation des effectifs en maternité
à la suite des premières mobilisations
vous avez confié avec le secrétaire
d'état en charge de l'enfance et de la
famille une mission à l'igas sur
l'évolution de la profession de
sage-femme en effet malgré toutes les
compétences requises et laitages assumer
les sages femmes ont aujourd'hui le
sentiment de ne pas être reconnus à la
juste valeur du travail effectué et pire
encore elles ont parfois l'impression
d'être maltraitante faute de pouvoir
accorder le temps nécessaire à chaque
patiente une situation qui s'explique
aussi d'ailleurs par une pin pénurie de
gynécologues dans les hôpitaux elles le
disent tout monsieur le ministre les
sages femmes ont à coeur de s'occuper au
mieux des patientes vous avez déjà
monsieur le ministre formulé plusieurs
propositions pour la profession ainsi
les sages femmes travaillant à l'hôpital
recevront et vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure à partir de janvier 2022 une
prime et une hausse salariale c'est bien
c'est un premier pas mais vous savez
c'est loin de répondre à toutes les
revendications et surtout à la
profondeur du malaise il me semble que
d'autres recommandations de l'igas
mériteraient plus d'attention de la part
du gouvernement comme l'a dit ma
collègue pomérols tout à l'heure des
dirigeants d'établissements privés m'ont
interpellé sur cette question et
j'imagine aisément qu'ils ne sont pas
les seuls à s'inquiéter de la situation
actuelle monsieur le ministre quel autre
réponse allez vous apporter pour traiter
ces iniquités et répondre aux demandes
légitimes de cette belle profession
pour vous répondre la parole est commise
de solidarité de la santé monsieur lieux
et rock
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur de mini merci pour
votre question j'ai déjà répondu sur les
revalorisations je le redis un ville et
hôpital 100 millions d'euros sinon en
ville et hôpital 100 millions d'euros de
plus par an de la nation pour les vins
mime sages femmes exerçant dans notre
pays c'est la plus grosse revalorisation
ou pouvait estimer que ce n'est pas
suffisant mais honnêtement par sa femme
ça représente plus de 4000 euros de
revalorisation par an je pense qu
nettement on est on a quand même fait un
geste conséquents en matière de
formation la demande portait sur la
sixième année avec frédéric vidal nous
avons dit on est d'accord donc on est en
train avec une mission de l'inspection
générale de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche de préfigurer cette
sixième année donc c'était
revalorisation on les a donnés la
sixième année nous l'avons fait sur
l'émission il y avait une demande dans
le cadre de l'inspection générale du
rapport devra permettre de faire des
arrêts de travail du dépistage de la
prise en charge des infections
sexuellement transmissibles
nous l'avons autorisé vous l'avait votée
dans le cadre la ppl dits tristes à
l'assemblée nationale il y avait une
demande pour développer le statut de sa
chambre et ferrante nous l'avons fait et
désormais ses astuces existent et nous
pouvons le décliner avec la profession
il y avait des demandes qui portait sur
des centres périnataux de proximité et
sur des maisons de naissance nous
l'avons fait et dans le dernier budget
de la sécurité sociale non seulement
j'ai généralisée mais en plus nous avons
développé avec la création de vingt
centre de périnatalité et de et de
maisons de naissances supplémentaires
monsieur le sénateur il arrive souvent
qu'on fasse l'objet de d'interpellations
par des syndicats qu'il y ait des
conflits sociaux c'est ainsi que dans
notre pays il ya des fois on ne peut pas
répondre et on explique pourquoi on peut
pas répondre le s'agissant des
sages-femmes ce que c'est une profession
que j'affectionne que je connais bien et
que j'ai à coeur comme toute la
représentation nationale de soutenir je
les ai réunis en vision pour celles et
ceux qui le souhaitaient il n'avait plus
de 8500 sages-femmes connectés pendant
une heure pour des échanges libres au
cours desquelles j'ai fait ces annonces
ce que je n'y avais une demande de
confirmer leur statut médical dans la
fonction publique c'est le cas de
changer la gouvernance pour qu'elle
puisse être représentée au même titre
que les médecins parlent à la direction
médicale établissements je fais passer
des circulaires pour que ce soit le cas
reste coi reste une demande qui porte
sur le fait d'accorder le statut de
praticien hospitalier c'est-à-dire de
médecins hospitaliers au même titre que
des gynécos des chirurgiens cardiaques
et c'est ce que l'igas ne souhaite pas
compte tenu du fait qu'un chirurgien
à 12 ans d'études et qu'aujourd'hui on
s'acharne à cinq ans même si on va les
passer à 6 ans mais il n'empêche que le
en termes de revalorisations salariales
je vous dis on n'est pas loin des 4000
euros en fin de carrière c'est un geste
fort de la nation manifestement pas
suffisant pour tout le monde mais on
peut pas dire qu'on n'a rien fait voilà
monsieur
2001 par l'état d'autres collègues cdh
rials pour le groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
monsieur le ministre vous venez de
publier une circulaire censée répondre à
la situation des élèves transgenre dans
le milieu scolaire il s'agit d'un sujet
grave que je regrette de voir traiter
ainsi avec tant de légèreté si les temps
fous s'il est un fait que la société
doit prendre en compte des situations
d'élèves ou de jeunes confrontés à ce
que l'on appelle désormais une dysphorie
de genre cette circulaire place
désormais les directeurs d'établissement
les personnels enseignants en charge
d'instituer une nouvelle identité de
genre choisi par l'élève à partir de son
seul ressenti intime ce qui se traduit
entre autres par un changement de prénom
monsieur le ministre est bien de la
responsabilité des équipes enseignantes
d'être à la fois officiers de fêtes de
l'état civil pour officialiser une
identité d'usagers et des gendarmes en
charge de faire respecter cette nouvelle
identité au sein de leur établissement
est d'ailleurs sous peine de quelle
sanction monsieur le ministre la
responsabilité de l'équipe éducative
consiste à écouter orienter et protéger
les élèves mais est ce bien le rôle des
enseignants de les accompagner dans une
transition identitaire individuelles et
de l'opérer en première ligne comme vous
le préconisez avec une médiation avec
les familles pour favoriser cette
transition par ce texte vous incitez
également d accompagnement de transition
précoce souvent irréversibles et dont
les conséquences peuvent être négatif
pour le jeune et son équilibre car
effectué trop précipitamment s'il est
légitime de prendre en considération ces
situations quand elles existent et de
leur apporter une réponse adaptée et
individualiser la proche de ce texte est
tout autre vous demandez par exemple
changement des règlements intérieurs sur
les tenues vestimentaires pour faire des
exceptions à la règle c'est un pas de
plus vers une stratégie de
déconstruction qui nie l'altérité des
sexes et va créer de plus de difficultés
qu'elle ne valant résoudre nous aurions
préféré vous voir choisir l'inspiration
chez le philosophe jean jacques rousseau
plutôt que celle activistes militante du
même nom lorsqu'il dit que les vrais
besoins n'ont jamais d'excès monsieur le
ministre l'école est-elle encore ce
sanctuaire au sein duquel on protège les
élèves des excès des violences de la
société comme des discours militant mais
sous la porte pour vous répondre la
parole est qu'à la secrétaire d'état
chargés d'éducation prioritaire
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur cédric vial je vous prie
d'excuser jean michel blanquer requis
est retenu et donc je vais vous répondre
alors je vous remercie d'avoir posé
cette question qui me permet de dire à
nouveau que la mobilisation de toutes et
de tous évidemment est indispensable
pour créer des environnements scolaires
qui soit propice favorables et qui
garantisse le droit des élèves bien sûr
à l'intégrité au bien-être à la santé et
à la sécurité alors en effet avec jean
michel blanquer nous avons fait le choix
de publier un texte qui a la foi posent
les enjeux du sujet et en même temps
d'un des éléments des éléments de
compréhension des éléments pour
l'accompagnement des situations
individuelles comme vous l'avez dit et
puis des éléments pour bâtir une
politique de prévention de la
transphobie à l'échelle de
l'établissement scolaire
alors monsieur le sénateur cette
circulaire n'a pas vocation à traiter
l'ensemble de la question des mineurs
transgenres ou en questionnement sur
leur identité de genre mais elle
s'adresse au personnel afin de faciliter
de donner des clés pour accompagner et
protéger tous les élèves et en
particulier de prendre en compte les
élèves transgenres c'est un texte qui a
été écrit je le répète alain temps à
l'attention des personnels pour
harmoniser des pratiques et notamment
demander l'usagé du prénom choisi de la
reconnaissance de l'état entités du
genre dès lors que les représentants les
représentants légaux ont donné leur
accord mais surtout monsieur le sénateur
c'est un texte qui est écrit pour que
les élèves transgenres puisse réussir
leur scolarité dans les mêmes conditions
que tous les autres élèves et que la
reconnaissance de leur identité de genre
corollaire à leur réussite soit un
impératif qui s'impose à tous parce que
en tant qu'élève bien sûr leurs droits
sont les mêmes que ceux de tous les
autres je vous remercie
[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue thierry
cozic pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'économie
représenté par le cedus optent pour la
3è larmes mes chers collègues
onze mille 300 milliards de dollars ce
chiffre et si vertigineux qu'il ne
représente plus rien dans l'imaginaire
collectif
si ce n'est qu'il pèse 5 fois le pib de
la france
nul besoin d'être aux fonctionnaires
pour comprendre que l'évasion fiscale
nous coûte un pognon de dengue offshore
l'x china l'x panama peppers et j'en
passe qu'est ce qui a changé depuis pas
grand chose si ce n'est qu'au fil des
révélations les chiffres sont toujours
plus colossaux chacun de ces scandales
vient révéler votre incapacité à
surveiller efficacement
ces territoires opaques du monde
financier
alors que d'aucuns disserte doctement
sur l'idée de travailler jusqu'à 67 ans
pourquoi pas 80 tant qu on y est
lorsqu'il s'agit traquer de
fantomatiques acheteurs d'écrans plats
le gouvernement s'est déployé toute
l'énergie qui lui sied mais dès lors que
l'on touche aux importants il est aux
abonnés absents
nous devons sortir du mythe que le
système offshore est un outil neutre qui
serait simplement mal utilisée par
certains le système étant lui porter des
inégalités en ce qu'il permet de rompre
le contrat social et pousse les plus
riches à faire sécession
d'aucuns sur ses bancs étaient bien plus
prolixe lorsqu'il s'agissait d'aborder
le séparatisme religieux je note qu'il
se font moins sonore lorsque ce cp
séparatistes se fait financiers mais je
ne doute pas mes chers collègues que
vous sortirez prochainement de ce
silence assourdissant
pas d'argent magique donc pour les
services publics mais beaucoup d'argent
caché au service des plus riches
monsieur le ministre pouvez vous nous
donner clairement les mesures vous
comptez mettre en place afin de stopper
cette hémorragie de fuite des capitaux
français dans des paradis fiscaux
[Applaudissements]
en charge les cours publics monsieur
olivier dussopt
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur cozic gelé indiqué tout à
l'heure en réponse aux questions
précédentes il ya la direction générale
des finances publiques à ma demande et
celle de bruno le maire nous tellement
mobilisés pour exploiter analysé
l'intégralité des données révélées par
la presse correspondant est ce qui est
désormais appelé la sphère pandora l'x
pandora paper je tiens à préciser que
cette affaire est une affaire
internationale qui concerne 117 pays
dans lesquels 600 journalistes ont mené
des investigations et les chiffres
énormes estime que vous avez rappelé ne
concerne évidemment pas la france j'ai
eu l'occasion de dire tout à l'air qu'à
la suite des investigations de dire ils
sont générale des finances publiques
dans un autre scandale financier les
panama peppers ce sont 600 57 dossiers
qui avaient été régularisées les autres
dossiers n'étant pas des dossiers
concernant des contribuables français
vous me demander que faire nous
appliquons la loi de 2018 je les dis
avec la création d'une politique fiscale
nos services malgré le confinement
malgré l'arrêt des contrôles sur pièces
en 2020 du fait du confinement ont
permis l'encaissement de presque 8
milliards d'euros de redressement et de
fonction seulement france en matière de
lutte contre la fraude fiscale au niveau
européen les échanges de données qui
penche sur 84 millions de comptes qui
concerne plusieurs milliards ou
plusieurs milliers de milliards d'actifs
ont permis à l'europe de détecter des
fraudes et d'encaisser plus de 100
milliards d'euros de revenus
complémentaires nous avons mis en place
des systèmes nouveaux y compris
d'information est ce la raison pour
laquelle nous avons pérennisé par
exemple le système de la rémunération
des aviseurs système proposé par votre
collègue du de l'assemblée nationale
christine pires bonne nous avons aussi
développé des systèmes d'analysé de
données en mauvais français de
datamining cette analyse aux données et
analyse des data nous a permis de
détecter 800 millions de fraude l'année
dernière ce sont 800 millions de
redressement pardon qui ont été permis
par l'analyse des données et par
l'intelligence artificielle
je ne regrette qu'une chose c'est qu'au
delà de votre colère aujourd'hui vous
auriez pu voter ni deux les outils et
les crédits qui permettent à
l'administration fiscale de développer
cette analyse de données vous n'avez pas
fait
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue à la houppe ère pour le groupe
l'est républicain
monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
madame la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche et de
l'innovation
suite à votre réforme du premier cycle
des études de médecine des étudiants en
médecine en première année de médecine à
paris ont eu une vingtaine de minutes
pour préparer un oral sur les thèmes
aussi variés que le racisme ou les
barrières de corail l'idée étant de
diversifier les profils des futurs
soignants en leur posant des questions
de société admettons le résultat c'est
qu'une quarantaine d'étudiants en tête
des classements à l'écrit n'ont pas dû
avoir des avis suffisamment éclairé sur
la vie sous marine
cet oral qui comptait pour 70% de leurs
notes fidal les a déclassé barrant ainsi
leur passage en seconde année sans
possibilité de redoubler
cette justice là gland flagrante a eu
pour résultat plusieurs saisine de la
justice par ses étudiants médecins j'ai
moi même vécu la dure réalité d'une
première année de médecine pendant
laquelle on sacrifier toute une vie tout
au profit des révisions je partage
totalement leur sentiment d'avoir été
volés
madame le ministre que comptez-vous
faire aujourd'hui pour ces étudiants
sacrifiés
madame la ministre je vous demande de
réétudier leur dossier pour leur part
nette pour leur permettre de devenir les
médecins dans notre pays a besoin
merci pour vous répondra par lettre à la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur de
la recherche et de l'innovation
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur ou perd
tout d'abord permettez moi de saluer les
dizaines de milliers d'étudiants qui
cette année démarre ou poursuivre leurs
études de santé et de leur dire à quel
point leur présence a été importante
durant la fin de la pandémie que nous
venons de vous permets moi de moi de
saluer les les dix sept mille six cent
soixante jeunes qui cette année entament
leur formation médicale en deuxième
année ils sont
2663 de plus que l'année dernière pour
répondre précisément à votre question
monsieur le sénateur je pense que
personne ici ne souhaiterait que les
jurys de concours soient
menées par les politiques
les jurys et les épreuves que vous
évoquez elles ont été pensés par des
professeurs de médecine pour recruter
leurs futurs collègues et je crois que
de ce point de vue là eh bien ça me
paraît important que l'on puisse
respecter ce que souhaite le jury mais
revenons-en à la vraie question qui a
été posée par par cette loi qui a permis
de modifier profondément l'ensemble des
études de santé bien sûr le numerus à
perthus et je viens de le dire plus de
2600 jeunes de plus dans les études de
santé mais surtout la possibilité de
démarrer ses études partout sur le
territoire la possibilité de faire des
stages d'externat et d'internât partout
sur le territoire comment voulez vous
que l'on lutte contre les déserts
médicaux en concentrant toute la
formation médicale dans 34 grandes
villes françaises comment voulez vous qu
après dix ans 12 ans ou 14 ans d'études
les jeunes retrouvent donc le vrai sujet
c'est comment est ce que l'on fait pour
arrêter la désertification médicale et à
ces jeunes ce que je dis c'est que tout
est fait et pour qu'il puisse en
deuxième année présentée à nouveau ce
concours et que bien sûr nous ferons
tout pour les accompagner dans les
établissements
shoppers
madame la ministre vous n'avez pas
répondu à ma question et je reconnaître
votre membres votre manque d'empathie
ça n'a rien à voir avec la politique
notre pays peut-il se permettre de
sacrifier plusieurs dizaines d'étudiants
brillants appelé à devenir de bons
citoyens sous prétexte qu'ils n'ont pas
d'avis sur des sujets de société
je ne le pense pas madame la ministre si
j'ai besoin d'informations sur les
coraux je ne vais pas chez mon médecin
mais j'appelle l'ifremer
la parole
[Applaudissements]
hilton toi collègues
alain cadec pour le groupe l'est
républicain vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
transition écologique dont je regrette
d'ailleurs l'absence
lors de son déplacement en polynésie
française
fin juillet le président de la
république a déclaré à propos du
développent du développement des parcs
éoliens je le cite là où il crée trop de
tension dénaturer défigurent le paysage
il faut savoir soit les adapter soit il
renonce et je saisis l'occasion de cette
déclaration pour attirer votre attention
sur le parc éolien offshore de la baie
de saint brieuc
ce parc est d'abord un projet mal n'est
en effet sans tenir compte des
particularités des fonds marins sans
étude d'impact sérieuses et sans
véritable concertation avec les
principaux utilisateurs de cet espace
maritime que sont les pêcheurs ce projet
est en phase est en passe par don de
faire l'unanimité contre lui il apparaît
clairement que les travaux nécessaires à
son implantation provoque la destruction
des fonds marins ces désordres
préjudicielle la diversité à la
biodiversité vont impacter directement
les activités de la pêche aux
pardonnez-moi mais j'en ai marre de ce
masque la pêche côtière et par
conséquent le gisements de coquilles
saint-jacques de la baie par ailleurs
défigurer le paysage du cap fréhel
classé au titre des grands sites de
france en implantant 62,0 liane 2 207
mètres de haut à 15 kilomètres des côtes
serait un non sens pour mémoire la tour
montparnasse et 210 m que les choses
soient claires
messieurs les ministres mesdames les
ministres les énergies renouvelables et
en particulier l'éolien offshore doivent
être développées en complément de notre
production nucléaire
mais pas n'importe où pas à n'importe
comment et pas à n'importe quel prix
madame la ministre compte tenu des
propos du président de la république le
gouvernement serait-il prêt à renoncer à
ce projet et à réfléchir et une ambition
alternative plus réaliste et plus adapté
aux caractéristiques de nos côtes je
pense ici à l'éolien flottant qui a la
particularité d'être implanté plus loin
des côtes et qui ne nécessite pas de
forage profond et alors cerise sur le
gâteau le conseil d'état ayant relevé
des régularité le pnf vient de se saisir
du dossier d'attribution de ce marché à
iberdrola sans commentaire oui je vous
demande de remettre le masque nous avons
une discipline collective je demande à
chacun de respecter la discipline
collective
pour vous répondre la parole qu'à la
secrétaire d'état en charge de la
biodiversité vadam bérenger rabat donner
la parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur qu'avec vous le
savez pour atteindre nos objectifs
climatiques nous avons besoin
d'électrifier nos usages et dans ce
contexte pour garantir
l'approvisionnement électrique des
français nous devons développer
massivement les énergies renouvelables
dont l'éolien terrestre et et maritimes
avec notre pays qui dispose du deuxième
gisement potentiel et d'europe pour
l'éolien en mer c'est donc une source
d'énergie qui est durable qui est sûre
qui est compétitive et qui n'émet pas de
co2 elle est donc une chance une chance
pour la bretagne ici sur le parc de
saint brieuc mais une chance pour le mix
énergétique français et pour le climat
nous avons donc l'idée de produire
l'équivalent de la consommation
électrique de 800 35000 habitants en
bretagne là où en termes de sécurité
d'approvisionnement
cette région importe 85 % de sa
consommation
ce parc il sera donc pourvoyeur
d'emplois avec des fondations qui seront
fabriqués à brest le port de
construction et le port de maintenance
qui seront installés dans les côtes
d'armor il aura un impact visuel limité
vous le savez l'équivalent d'une
silhouette à horizon de l'autre bout
d'un stade de foot et nous le savons
également les pêcheurs professionnels
qui s'en sont inquiétés ont été entendus
les parties prenantes ont pris part à
des à des dialogues à une concertation
très très large et d'ailleurs certaines
adaptations ont été faites sur ce projet
pour les écouter avec donc un projet
éolien dont il n'est pas question qu'ils
excluent les usages de la mer et
d'ailleurs vous le savez les activités
de pêche qui resteront possibles
l'impact environnemental
marin ou sur l'avifaune a également été
étudiée notamment au travers d'études tu
cnrs nous avons donc la plus grande
attention aux risques environnementaux
sur toute la conduite du chantier et
dans son exploitation évidemment comme
vous nous avons été très sensibles à
l'incident qui s'est produit cet été il
s'avère que quand nous avons caractérisé
ces huiles elles se sont révélées
biodégradables selon les normes
classiques il n'est pourtant pas
question évidemment de voir ces
incidents se reproduire le des travaux
dd fait d'ailleurs sur le sur le navire
foreurs nous avons donc ici je crois
après neuf ans presque 10 depuis
l'attribution de ce parc éolien un
projet qui a su évoluer pour tenir
compte des attentes et des besoins des
parties prenantes des études inédites
sur les impacts de nombreux contentieux
qui n'ont jamais remis en cause le
projet est donc en transparence et avec
la plus grande vigilance nécessité je
crois de laisser enfin ce projet se
faire merci monsieur le premier ministre
la halle de monsieur le ministre merci
non prochaine question d'actualité
auront lieu le 13 octobre à 15 heures le
mercredi 13 octobre
si on sait va être suspendu sera reprise
à 16h30 pour l'examen d'une proposition
de loi tendant à permettre l'examen par
le parlement de la ratification de
l'ordonnancé
du 2 juin 2021 portant réforme de
l'encadrement supérieur de la fonction
publique de l'état la séance est
suspendue
[Musique]
voilà donc pour cette séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
dans un instant on va refaire les kag
avec mes invités on va débriefer on va
longuement décrypter cette séance mais
sans perdre de temps tout de suite on va
retrouver jérôme qui est dans
l'hémicycle jérôme qu'avez vous retenu
de cette séance et bien steve ince était
le sujet le plus attendu les questions
sur les révélations des pandora paper
sein cette enquête mondiale montrant
l'ampleur de l'évasion fiscale est bien
comme attendu lors des questions sur le
sujet cela s'est animé dans l'hémicycle
nathalie goulet d'abord pour le groupe
centriste a lancé les hostilités
rappelant que l'union européenne a
retiré hier de la liste des paradis
fiscaux trois pays dont les seychelles
elle a également dénoncé l'indécence de
cette fraude massive
écoutez la
quelle mesure entendez vous prendre pour
lutter contre la fraude et l'évasion
fiscale alors que notre dette flamber
pendant que certains cachent des
millions dans les paradis fiscaux nos
étudiants font la queue devant les
banques alimentaires et nos agriculteurs
se débattant des difficultés infernale
olivier dussopt pour le gouvernement
alors fait la même réponse 1 que bruno
le maire il hier à l'assemblée
s'engageant à lancer des régularisations
et poursuite surtout les français cité
par la presse puis éric bocquet pour les
communistes a lancé la deuxième lame
selon ses propres mots ce spécialiste de
la lutte contre l'évasion fiscale a
enjoint le gouvernement à agir écoutez
le
choqué quand tous nos citoyens sont
ulcérés par ses révélations incessantes
faite par la presse ces dernières années
pour les milliardaires concernés
responsables politiques de très haut
niveau sportif les trafics en tous
genres l'objectif est d'échapper à
l'impôt et aux juges grâce à tête à
cette industrie de l'opacité
le problème est systémique
olivier lui saute alors repris le micro
il a rappelé que les services fiscaux
avaient déjà fait lors de précédentes
lors de précédents scandales
comme les panama peppers il y a cinq ans
écoutez ce que la france avait récupéré
à l'époque l'administration fiscale
française a identifié un certain nombre
de contribuables français concernés que
nous avons menées à leur terme 657
dossier x de régularisation soit de
redressement soit négociée qui ont fait
l'objet d'une judiciarisation et cela
permit à l'état français de recouvrer
plus de 100 millions d'euros de
régularisations hautes fonctions à la
suite
mais pardonnez moi monsieur le sénateur
à solide mais vous dites onze mille
milliards comme si c'était un
demi-milliard français je vous parle des
657 contribué à de france est détectée
dans panama peppers vous devrez vous en
féliciter et féliciter l'administration
plutôt que de faire des comparaisons qui
n'ont ni queue ni tête permettez moi de
vous le dire
200 millions d'euros récupérés bien trop
peu en au goût de nombreux sénateurs qui
ont chahuté le ministre enfin éric
bocquet dans sa réplique a fait trois
propositions pour agir au plus vite
première piste vous pouvez recréer les
postes de contrôleurs dé le projet loi
de finances qui vient est au parlement
dans quelques jours pour rappel 38 mille
emplois ont été supprimés depuis 2002
dans les finances publiques 2 vous
pouvez créer l'observatoire de lutte
contre la fraude fiscale annoncée en
2018 jamais mis en place nous sommes
toujours candidats à titre bénévole 3 la
france va présider le conseil de l'union
européenne à partir de janvier 2022
l'union européenne a décidé hier de
retirer de la liste des paradis fiscaux
les seychelles effectivement en plein
coeur des révélations du dernier
scandale inscrivait à l'agenda de ce
semestre une mise à jour de cette liste
en y incluant notamment le luxembourg et
chypre une chose est sûre les sénateurs
ne veulent pas en rester là eux qui ont
déjà mené des missions d'information des
commissions dans lequel est sur le sujet
ils vont s'emparer du nouveau scandale
des pandora papers nathalie goulet et
espère que son groupe utilisera ce qu'on
appelle ici un son droit tirage pour
demander la création d'une nouvelle
commission duc denquête sur ce sujet
merci beaucoup jérôme 16h20 sur public
sénat dans quelques instants on va
refaire les cas qu'on va décrypter on va
analyser ce qui s'est passé pendant
cette séance mais tout de suite on va
retrouver quentin qu'elle mais qui est
en salle des conférences quentin vous
êtes à mai avec amélie de montchalin la
ministre de la fonction publique elle
est assez remontée je crois contre les
sénateurs oui tout à fait steve la
ministre qui est assez remonté contre
les sénateurs on peut le dire bonjour
madame la ministre effectivement on va
voir dans quelques minutes dans
l'hémicycle et bien comme cela une
coalition l air centristes socialistes
écologie dénoncer votre réforme de la
haute fonction publique les sénateurs
qui vont saborder leur propre
proposition de loi c'est exceptionnel
c'est du jamais vu qu'est ce que vous
pensez de leur initiative j'entends
certains sénateurs dire que je serai la
contrainte et forcée d'abord je tiens à
dire que c'est toujours le gouvernement
est toujours à la disposition du
parlement et donc c'est pour moi c'était
prévu une grande chance
l'opportunité de pouvoir expliquer en
des termes clairs convaincant l'ampleur
de la transformation de l'état que nous
menons qui est donc fondée sur une
transformation de la haute fonction
publique parce que vous savez en france
si on veut transformer le pays il faut
transformer l'état et si vous
transformez l'état faut commencer par de
hautes fonctions league après j'entends
que les sénateurs ont beaucoup de choses
à dire sur les ordonnances moi j'ai
beaucoup de choses à dire sur ma vision
d'état sur la réforme que nous menons
est sûr aussi il faut le rappeler
l'ambition transformatrices qui est
celle du président la république depuis
2007 sur un sujet où tous ses
prédécesseurs ont essayé et ont échoué
oui vous dites que vous n'êtes pas
convoqué mais effectivement vous avez
recours à une ordonnance alors
m'explique aux téléspectateurs ça veut
dire qu'il n'y a pas de débat
parlementaire vous enjambez le parlement
pour prendre des décisions sur cette
réforme de notre fonction publique et
c'est ça non que les sénateurs verts
jean-pierre sueur se rapproche pour vous
écouter mais je tiens aussi à rappeler
quelque chose on n'est pas ici en train
de mener une réforme inconstitutionnelle
antidémocratique une ordonnance et quoi
de notre constitution c'est un texte que
prend le gouvernement parce que le
parlement l'y autorisent je suis
aujourd'hui en train de défendre une
réforme parce que j'ai été autorisé par
l'article 59 du noah de 2019 qui a été
voté au sénat modifié au sénat les
sénateurs m'ont autorisé à prendre ces
textes et je suis aujourd'hui en toute
transparence devant eux comme je l'étais
avant que cette ordonnance soit écrit
que j'ai été après qu'elle ait été
écrite et donc je crois qu'il faut
rappeler aux français on n'est pas en
train de faire de l'anti constitutionnel
on est en train de respecter la
constitution de nous tenir prêts mais
moi j'aimerais dire ap quelque chose le
débat que j'attendais aujourd'hui ok je
m'étais préparé c'était un débat projet
contre projet j'ai été député j'étais
parlementaire pour moi l'honneur la
parlementaire c'est de traduire sa
vision en des amendements je constate
que si a pas d'amendement c'est
peut-être parce qu a pas de vision alors
c'est bien dommage allant sur le fond de
la réforme si vous le voulez bien avec
ma dernière question les socialistes les
socialistes disent que votre vision de
l'état et bien c'est une vision où les
préfets deviennent des contractuels et
des intermittents on peut comprendre que
ça peut inquiéter certains français sont
d'abord les préfets ils sont essentiels
on les enfants dans leur métier mais
voyez bien qu'on peut renforcer un
métier sans croire au corporatisme ou à
logique de corps évidemment que nous
voulons garder d'abord le statut de la
fonction publique là où certains
notamment chez rebecca va le supprimer
ensuite nous gardons une haute vision de
ce qu'est les tentes notamment en
investissant sur la formation sur le
recrutement sur ce sens de l'état ce
sens d'intérêt général qui au corps et
au coeur de la fonction lui mais pour ça
si vous en revenez même au général de
gaulle lui même il avait en 45
souhaitait que tous les métiers
d'encadrement de l'état soient
regroupées dans un même corps c'est la
même logique qui nous pousse aujourd'hui
à prendre une décision nous nous
élargissons cette vision pour lyon
explique aux français qu est-ce qu on
cherche on cherche un état qui répondent
aux défis du 21e siècle un état qui soit
organisé pour les servir au plus près du
terrain et donc un état qui s'adapte un
monde qui a changé sur un sujet la haute
fonction publique qui n'a été en rien
modifier adapter depuis 1945 c'est
nécessaire aujourd'hui et c'est
l'ambition qu'on porte résolument avec
le présent la république merci amélie de
montchanin et c'est le débat qui va se
tenir cet après midi on l'a bien compris
en séance ici au sénat merci merci
beaucoup quand un calme et allez on va
refaire ces questions d'actualité avec
mes invités ici en plateau bonjour marc
philippe daubresse sénateurs l ère du
nord merci d'être avec nous racheter mal
sénateur ps du val-d'oise qui étaient
avec nous bonjour et pierre ouzoulias
sénateurs communistes des hauts-de-seine
bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec nous
on va parler des pandora paper simple
parce que c'était évidemment un des
grands sujets de cette séance de
questions d'actualité après luc slick
après panama peppers après paradise
peppers voici donc les pandora peppers
marc philippe daubresse est ce que ces
révélations vous ont étonné non pas
vraiment parce que c'est la suite c'est
comme une série lh et la fraude fiscales
on a plusieurs saisons bon c'est
d'ailleurs assez
ironique de constater que monsieur du
soft qui siégeait il ya quelques années
dans le même groupe que monsieur jérôme
cahuzac à l'époque tu avais pas beaucoup
réagi quand monsieur cahuzac nous a dit
j étais aussi les yeux dans les yeux que
il n'avait jamais fait de fraude fiscale
donc on voit bien qu'ils aient un sujet
de fond ya d un certain nombre de
collègues sur tous les membres y compris
mureaux je le dis tranquillement mon
collègue éric bocquet qui en ont fait
des propositions de me semble-t-il tout
à fait pertinente il faut aller est
évidemment beaucoup plus loin et ces
questions ne sont pas que du ressort du
gouvernement français que le que
l'administration de l'économie et des
finances vérifie évidemment s'il n'y a
pas un certain nombre de contribuables
français qui ont fauté et ils doivent
être sanctionnés lourdement il faut
traiter le sujet structurelles de fond
et c'est et ça se traite beaucoup au
niveau européen et donc il faut qu'on
aille beaucoup plus loin on a fait nous
tous les sénateurs de tous groupes
confondus des tas de propositions là
dessus des missions je pense qu'il faut
maintenant passer à la vitesse
supérieure et on voit bien je donne
qu'un exemple par exemple le luxembourg
a certain nombre de pays passés au
travers d'un certain nombre de crible
alors que tout le monde sait que ils
servent de paradis fiscaux il fallait
plus loin il faut peut-être mettre sur
pied une commission denquête rachid
teman donc faut mettre en place une
commission denquête ça mais ça s'apprend
de mer puis non la vraie question vous
avez vous même site et toute une série
de scandales je crois que d'abord pour
les français c'est ils ne peuvent pas
comprendre que ils ont étiré la langue
chaque mois et que on leur parle de
plusieurs dizaines centaines de
milliards d'euros qui transitent comme
ça etc la question maintenant c'est que
faire les rapports yona des provisions
et n'a maintenant c'est comment on fait
donc bien sûr un niveau français mais
avant tout nous avons là la présence
française pendant six mois et je crois
que la tireuse janvier la question qui
est posée maintenant c'est quelle
proposition la france fera et comment
elles france antilles mais rappliquer
qu'est ce qu'on fait à jouer les juges
devaient poursuivre ça suppose que par
exemple on peut très bien avoir le bleu
la présence française pourrait échanger
avec les chambres échangé avec son
groupe politique par exemple pour dit
voilà je vais donc diriger l'europe
pendant six mois quelles sont les
propositions sur cette question
notamment que vous pouvez porter vous au
niveau de l'état et donc je crois que
associer l'ensemble des formations
politiques qui siègent au parlement par
est une bonne méthode et deuxième chose
il ya un consensus a su droite gauche
mais permettez-moi dire un mot même sur
son agence ont dû j'ai entendu il ya
quelques semaines des gens défilent et
notamment un ministre de l'éducation
nationale sur les français qui utilisent
et quelques peut-être sans aucune preuve
d' allianz a jamais été montré que la
prime pour la rentrée scolaire est
illisible pour les écrans plats bon je
les entends pas la tuer michel blanc
caire je les entends pas parce que on
jeter sans aucune preuve encore une fois
ceux de quelques français la part alors
pour le coup par contre sur cette
question là où des centaines de
milliards d'euros qui se baladent le vla
il ya un silence assourdissant
du gouvernement
le gouvernement réagit mais par ronde il
fallait dénoncer entre guillemets les
[__] de pau en camp par le couple
pour le coup sûr des gens qui sont
milliardaires qui en plus font cela il
n'y a pas un mot alors but est qu'ils
veulent
et puis je vous ferai réagir juste après
les informations dont le gouvernement
dispose et à travers le gouvernement la
direction générale des finances
publiques selon les informations
révélées par la presse nous avons donné
avec bono maire des instructions
extrêmement clair la direction générale
des finances publiques consistant à
exploiter vérifier et analyser chacune
des données en sa disposition par ces
révélations médiatiques pour d'une part
vérifier si des contribuables français
sont concernés et le cas échéant
diligenter les contrôles fiscaux les
plus sévères qu'ils soient et les
cachant aussi en lien évidemment avec le
ministre à la justice les fonctions les
procédures judiciaires qui est s'avérait
les plus utiles non elles sont pas les
bras croisés
nôtre c'est un peu ce que nous dit le
gouvernement pierre ouzoulias ce qu'est
ce qu'on fait mal en france je vais vous
donner un chiffre en 2020 l'état a
récupéré seulement 8 milliards d'euros
sur les 100 milliards d'euros par an
d'évasion fiscale qu'est-ce qu'on fait
mal ou est-ce qu'on pêche mais je moi je
partage ce qui a été dit par par le
sénateur daubresse il ya un problème
structurel qui est fort qui est reconnu
et je rappelle parce que ça a été
rappelé lors des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement que tous les ans mais
tous les ans au moment de la discussion
budgétaire le sénat à la quasi unanimité
tous les sénateurs votent un certain
nombre d'amendements pour porter des
solutions structurelles à ce problème
c'est voté au sénat s'est refusé à
l'assemblée nationale et monsieur du
stop nous dit maintenant que le
gouvernement agit énormément matière
pourquoi parce qu'il ne veut pas
s'attaquer au fond du problème pourquoi
le fond le fond du problème c'est que
les états sont dans un système de
concurrence fiscale généralisée et que
si on ne s'attaque pas au paradis
fiscaux bien évidemment on met en
difficulté notre pays qui réclament
légitimement des impôts à ceux qui
gagnent le problème fondamental est là
et c'est pour ça qu'en effet l'une des
solutions c'est de porter le problème
devant l'europe juste une petite
parenthèse
pour les gars femmes google amazon etc
il n'y a pas de problème d'évasion
fiscale ils payent pas d'impôts donc ils
trichent pas ils payent plus d'impôts
ils ont trouvé la solution ils ont
complètement mis à l'écart leurs
bénéfices on peut pas on peut même pas
les attraper le point essentiel et je
finirai là dessus la république elle
repose sur quelque chose d'essentiel
c'est l'égalité devant l'impôt chaque
citoyen paie des impôts au prorata de ce
qu'ils gagnent c'est ce qu'il faut
restituer skis ps c'est ce qui permet de
financer les services publics et ce qui
permet aussi l'adhésion de tous les
citoyens à la république si on casse ça
on casse la république très rapidement
marc philippe daubresse quand je regarde
la liste actuelle 1 française des
paradis fiscaux dont vous parlez
monsieur uljasz il ya toujours aucun
membre de l'union européenne comment
vous expliquez ça je n'explique pas je
vous ai donné un exemple moi c'est à
dire depuis les
rivaux pandora paper on apprend par la
presse merci aux journalistes qu on fait
l'enquète on apprend que ya plusieurs
milliers de nouveaux paradis fiscaux qui
se sont créées depuis autrement dit dès
que quelque chose ait détecté d'autres
paradis fiscaux secret est donc biya
bien des états qui accueillent ces
paradis fiscaux y compris en europe là
si l'exemple et ont comme on veut pas se
fâcher avec certains états de l'union
européenne
eh bien on met de couvercle sur la
marmite je pense qu'au stade où nous en
sommes et c'est consensuel ici au sénat
qu'à l'assemblée mais ici au sénat à la
quasi totalité des groupes politiques
sont d'accord pour dire allons au fond
du sujet et les grands temps le
président de la république à la
présidence de l'europe pour six mois par
l'animation l'euro pour six mois il est
grand temps de s'y attaquer alors ça ça
fait consensus par quelque chose qui
fait peut-être un peu moins consensus et
le sujet du pouvoir d'achat le pouvoir
d'achat dont vous allez parler avec
françois patriat quentin calmer en salle
des conférences françois patriat le
président du groupe r dépit la
république en marche au sénat qui a sans
doute suivi les manifestations hier oui
tout à fait steve bonjour françois papon
j'ai effectivement on se posait la
question avec steve de ces mobilisations
sur le pouvoir d'achat on va commencer
avec ce sujet il ya des mobilisations
hier le premier ministre qui a parlé
d'un bouclier tarifaire pour lutter
contre ces effets d'augmentation des
prix d'énergie est-ce que c'est
suffisant pour et bien se prémunir d'une
forme de de mécontentement qui monterait
sur les questions de pouvoir d'achat
parmi les français vous savez sur
l'immigration comme sur le pouvoir
d'achat c'est difficile de faire
entendre aux français la réalité et sur
le pouvoir d'achat en particulier on
sent bien que pour regarder pendant
toute l'année moi j'ai pris mon gas oil
1 euros 19 il est remonté à 1 0 51 mais
pendant un an et demi ou latéraux 19
personne n'a demandé ou quoi que ce soit
on n'a pas en manque donc j'entends bien
que la hausse de l'énergie est une
préoccupation majeure faisant craindre
des risques de perte de pouvoir d'achat
et des risques d'inflation dans ce pays
grâce ce que le gouvernement répond à la
demande que lui font à la fois les
consommateurs et que le fonds même
des acteurs économiques aujourd'hui
alors d'une part en ayant le chèque
énergie d'autre part et le premier
ministre l'ont rappelé hier en bloquant
les taxes ce qui est un retour de quatre
milliards et demi on la demandait
baisser les taxes le gouvernement décrit
taxes on a entériné la hausse sur le gaz
de cette année pour l'année prochaine y
aura plus de hausse je pense que l'on le
gouvernement plus fortement répondu
qu'on a fait par le passé certains
parlent de communication avant
l'élection présidentielle avec en plus
une mesure qui viendrait prendre fin pis
leur demande de la campagne
présidentielle
avec donc cet effet de lissage qui
serait peut-être trompeur pour les
français qu'est ce que vous répondez à
cet argument est le genre de ceux qui ne
veulent pas entendre la réalité des
choses et qu'immédiatement conteste
toute forme de décision on est habitué
dans cet hémicycle en particulier ni que
le goût ce qu'a dit le gouvernement sait
que le lissage se ferait tout autant
qu'il y aurait en fonction et que si la
baisse n'était pas suffisante au
printemps 2000 était prévu il
augmenterait le lissage donc il s'agit
pas de parler d'élection présidentielle
on voit bien que là ce sont les dates
une hausse du prix du gaz aujourd'hui
une hausse du prix de l'électricité au
début de l'année c'est à cela qu'il faut
s'attaquer à faire en sorte que les
français n'est pas un payer trop cher de
ma peau leur énergie une dernière
question très rapide françois patriat
que dira la proposition d'anne hidalgo
de baisser les taxes sur les prix des
carburants pour je cite raccrocher des
catégories populaires à la transition
écologique que pense cette proposition
non je pense qu'anne hidalgo agit très
facilement quand il s'agit de baisser la
vitesse et de la bête à 30 km heure elle
pense que c'est aussi facile pour les
taxes aujourd'hui comme ça l a pas
entendu vraiment ce qu'a dit le
gouvernement on aura toujours des
propositions démagogiques et facile
facile entendre les ans il suffirait de
baisser les taxes elle sait très bien
elle maire de paris ça ne se fait pas
comme ça donc je prends cette
proposition comme dérisoire et non
responsable merci france à votre réelle
je laisse rejoindre l'hémicycle ce qui
évite vous allez suivre les débats cet
après midi mais c'est vrai produit une
question plus que ça merci merci
beaucoup quentin marc philippe daubresse
vous avez entendu françois patriat sur
cette action en faveur du pouvoir
d'achat des français qu'est ce que vous
en pensez par exemple quand jean castex
promet d'agir sur le levier fiscal si
les cours du gaz ne baisse pas d'ici au
printemps à ce que ne le suit veut dire
d'abord joué avec énergie et bien qu'à
une mémorisation des esprits chronique
en ce moment mais
le sujet pouvoir d'achat c'est le
premier sujet des français bien devant
l'ex-juge et d'immigration et la hausse
massive du prix du gaz et du prix de
l'électricité qui est indexé sur le gaz
qui est complètement aberrant compte
tenu de ce qui se passe en france montre
bien que le gouvernement n'est pas à la
hauteur des propositions le bouclier
monsieur castex est un tigre de papier
parce que c'est pas du tout vrai ce qu'a
dit monsieur patriat il dit on pourra
lycée après non non monsieur k sexe a
dit on fait un moratoire jusqu aux
élections présidentielles et après on va
attraper on va rattraper ce qu'il faudra
payer donc quelque part ils ne sont pas
décidés là aussi structurellement
s'attaquer au problème évidemment qu'il
va falloir à un moment se poser la
question de la tei pp pour pour
l'essence et le carburant et de détails
de la tva pour ce qui concerne l'énergie
comme essentielle qu'est l'électricité
ou le gaz et donc il faut évidemment
aller là dessus et ce sont des mesures
forts sur le pouvoir d'achat que les
français attendaient tout de suite et
pas des mesures dilatoires pour dire on
fait un moratoire et on rattrapera plus
tard ce qui fait quand même mesure
électorale en ce moment emballant échec
tous azimuts on ferait mieux d'aller sur
des mesures structurelles rajit et mal
cet amendement qui sera déposée entre le
budget 2022 pourra baisser les taxes sur
les prix du gaz vous allez voter vous
bien sûr mais comme le dit mon rôle est
d'accord avec le gouvernement la méthode
n'en suis pas d'accord avec ce que vous
dire par là c'est que aujourd'hui ce qui
est clair c'est que ce gouvernement
depuis qu'il est au pouvoir il s'attaque
ils s'attaquent au pouvoir d'achat des
français oui enfin s'attache à monter
soi-même annuel macron si je veux bien
que je termine mon propos moi je vais
déjà complète votre plein en venant à
paris les chiffres qui viennent de
l'insee donc l'agglo pouvoir d'achat
augmenter sous emmanuel macron alors je
viens mais là je sais pas où vous
définissez très bien je crois que nous
sommes un certain nombre à être sur le
terrain il n'y a pas un français il n'y
a pas un français que vous explique que
son pour un achat augmenter donc je veux
bien qu'on nous sorte ça et c'est la
réalité c'est que ce pouvoir là sous
gouvernement-là de la baisse de l'apl
puisqu'aujourd'hui la baisse
l'allocation chômage n'a fait que
baisser le point d'achat des plus
pauvres c'est une réalité et c'est
factuel oui c'est pas je veux pas ça si
je donne une réalité même menacé
l'arrivée donnez un ressenti comme
dirait le gouvernement
vous étiez là vous me parle exactement
ce que dit macron il faut que je vous
réponde la baisse des apl et la baisse
des allocations chômage s'est ain
millions de français touchés par la
belle en cause du chômage c'est une
réalité pas une perception une réalité
des gens qui ne vont plus à boire
d'alcool ou très peu et ça c'est
donc ça c'est une réalité bon choix la
question les crises et du gaz excusez
moi c'est pas la première qu'on subit
dans ce quinquennat
ça fait plusieurs lors battant il
invente une franchement une usine à gaz
quelques semaines avant les sons pré sel
et pour arriver avec son présentiel j'ai
entendu monsieur patriat franchement
faut être polytechnicien pour comprendre
son histoire de lissage ça n'existe pas
donc oui moi je crois qu anne hidalgo a
raison ils feront des mesures maintenant
sérieuse comme d'ailleurs le fonds
analysés les taxes c'est ça a expliqué
nous justement si vous voulez si vous
savez en fait fait une intervention sur
les quatre fois mais maintenant ça va
devenir compliqué si vous voulez cette
année je vais continuer à menzel
commerciale donc ce qu'elle propose je
rappelle que en espagne en italie il ya
des mesures de cette même nature donc
quand monsieur patriat dit c'est pas
responsables je crois qu'il a tort donc
madame ndiaye legault propose un algo
prouve une chose très simple c'est dire
que dans le prix ya ce qu'on achète et
là il ya un marché mondial et il ya des
taxes qu'on aime et qu'on y ajoute et
ben l'état est en capacité d'agir sur sa
partie dont d'avc tac ça voudra dire que
concrètement pour les français ça ne
fera pas cette hausse là je ne crois pas
que ce soit compliqué à comprendre je
crois que ces responsables et ça permet
effectivement de ne pas imputer le poil
achat des français c'est simple et c'est
cette mesure là que nous porterons parce
que je crois que c'est utile pour les
français et c'est une question
importante
je voulais dit on a eu une crise et j'y
joue dans ce pays personne ne l'a oublié
les gens sont descendus en lui parce que
il ya près de pouvoir d'achat donc c'est
là dessus qu'il faudra et je crois
qu'avec son plan set se jouera sur cette
question la pierre aux où la juge la
parole dans exactement deux minutes on
va d'abord aller voir jean mas siégeant
pour que racontez nous un peu ce qu'ont
retenu ce qui a retenu votre communauté
de cette séance d'actualité
et bien écoute ce qu'on a d'abord retenu
c'était beaucoup de questions
budgétaires évidemment comme chaque
année on est à l'automne donc c'était un
peu les questions olivier dussopt opte
aujourd'hui
le pauvre qui s'est retrouvé à beaucoup
à répondre à beaucoup de questions pas
seulement le pauvre parce qu'on l'a
aussi entendu répondre à des questions
sur les pandora snipers et sapho
reconnaître que les internautes sont
plutôt intéressés par ce sujet et par
ces questions on a notamment eu un
parallèle qui a été fait par beaucoup
d'internautes avec l'époque où on
parlait l'allocation de rentrée scolaire
qu'est ce qu'on en a pas dit
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire il ya
plusieurs semaines et la voilà des
internautes ont trouvé qu'on parlait
assez peu d pandora paper de ce scandale
de fraude fiscale olivier dussopt qui a
eu du coup l'occasion de deux rappelé
que le gouvernement n'avait pas rien
fait que les choses avaient déjà avancé
avec la loi de 2018 avec depuis les
pannes hamas papers déjà à l'époque où
des choses avaient été faites et des
gens avaient été redressée fiscalement
notamment des français et puis on a les
internautes ont retenu cette proposition
d'éric bocquet qui rappelait que il
était pro ils étaient ils étaient
volontaires pour faire partie de ce
fameux conseil de la fraude fiscale que
le prochain que le gouvernement avait
promis en 2018 mais que depuis on
n'avait jamais plus entendu parler en
tout cas les internautes se sont dit que
ce serait pas mal quand même que le
sujet de la fraude fiscale soit au coeur
de nos débats pour l'élection
présidentielle et que ça pouvait
commencer par le sénat voilà un petit
peu pour le principal sujet qui a
intéressé aujourd'hui steve simon coocoo
jean-pierre auzias je me retourne vers
vous sur cette question de la taxe sur
sur sur le gaz que propose anne hidalgo
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais deux
pas la suppression de la taxe l'inversé
d'après abc plus plus généralement il ya
il ya un mot que j'ai pas entendu dans
toutes nos discussions c'est le mot
salaire qui est essentiel la
revendication salariale et les mondiale
et concerne pas seulement la france elle
concerne le royaume uni elles concernent
les états unis parce que ça fait dix ans
que l'essentiel de la richesse qui est
produite ne va plus vers le salaire et
on arrive aujourd'hui il ya une
distorsion qui est impossible à vivre
pour les salariés et qui menace même la
notion du travail qu'est ce que vous
proposez sur une conférence salariale
le gouvernement à tous les moyens pour
augmenter les salaires moi je vais vous
prendre juste un exemple parce que le
gouvernement parle avec l'insee
on est sénateur de terrain on voit très
bien ce qui se passe dans nos terrains
moi je suis dans les hauts-de-seine qui
est pas un des particuliers un
département particulièrement pauvre
aujourd'hui
la la classe moyenne est menacé par
l'augmentation du coût de la vie et
notamment par le logement elle ne peut
plus le g la réalité est celle là et
comme ancien fonctionnaire je pourrais
vous dire que l'augmentation du pouvoir
d'achat des fonctionnaires
la dernière augmentation de la grille
indiciaire on sait plus quand elle est
c'est plus de 10 ans je crois il n'y a
pas eu d'augmentation de la grille
indiciaire donc il faut il faut il faut
absolument reprendre ce problème
problème de fond c'est est-ce qu'en
france aujourd'hui on peut vivre avec un
salaire la réponse pour une bonne partie
des français c'est non donc il faut
travailler sur le salaire la réponse
sera donc sans doute politique politique
on va en parler justement avec vous
quant à calmer quentin vous êtes avec
jérôme bascher le sénateur les
républicains de l'oise il ya un sondage
qui est sorti aujourd'hui quentin est ce
que vous pouvez peut-être faire réagir
le sénateur oui effectivement sim alors
avant de faire réagir sur les sondages
jérôme bascher on va parler d'abord de
ce qui se joue en ce moment ces jours ci
pour le parti a l'air bon jour jérôme
vachin jours on voit qu'on pourrait
attendre peut-être le congrès de début
décembre pour avoir un candidat pourrait
partis politiques est-ce que c'est pas
interminable de devoir attendre cette
échéance si c'est un peu interminable on
avait signé avec roger karoutchi à son
initiative un texte début juillet pour
demander qu'on avance sur le calendrier
et ça ne s'est pas fait on voit bien que
là on commence à rentrer dans une époque
interminables et ce qui concerne un peu
inquiétant c'est que les positions
commencent à se durcir alors que jusqu'à
présent tout allait bien donc il
faudrait peut-être quand même accéléré
et puis il faut accélérer aussi nos
partenariats car nous ne serons pas nous
ne gagnerons pas tout seuls les élèves
si nous voulons gagner il faut
rassembler largement la droite et le
centre et l'on peut parler de l'as du
sang vous êtes élus et des hauts de
france vous êtes un soutien de xavier
bertrand bien sûr ce que ça veut dire
concrètement pour être candidat à ce
qu'il faut qu'il accepte par exemple des
débats il faut qu est ce qu il faut
accélérer lé rencontre avec les autres
candidats parce que il ya bien un débat
en interne sur la désignation d'un non
alors il est certain que les rangs la
rencontre doit avoir moi je les écris si
on n'arrive pas à se parler avant le 4
décembre on se parlera pas après on l'a
bien vu de la fois dernière lors des
primaires la mayonnaise autour de
françois fillon n'a pas totalement pris
les équipes ne se sont pas totalement
rapprocher et donc je salue les
initiatives que xavier bertrand a prise
de contact et valérie pécresse ce
week-end de contacter aussi michel
barnier qui lui répond un peu plus
lentement mais ça doit passer plus
difficilement en savoie allez un dernier
mot donc sur ces sondages où on voit
qu'effectivement et bien et la
candidature d'eric zemmour est toujours
et bien aussi hot dans les sondages
voient même de plus en plus au fil des
des opinions des cadets des enquêtes
d'opinion qu'est ce que ça vous fait
penser à droite est ce qu'il ya une
question sur l'idéologie notamment qui
le sous tend alors l'idéologie 6 et son
idéologie sur la place des femmes dans
le monde mais ce n'est certainement pas
la mienne sur l'idéologie aussi sur ton
histoire l'immigration c'est une version
qu'il a je pense que le vrai sujet à l
intégration et sais que la république
est intègre plus c'est pas un sujet
d'immigration aujourd'hui c'est pas les
quantités incroyables qui se
déverseraient ça c'est des thèses du
front national mais je crois surtout
qu'eric zemmour il va finir par tuer
marine le pen et je ne serai pas très
étonné et bientôt au front national
maintenant elle n'en a plus la
présidence on le lâche sur la lâche pour
aller soutenir eric zemmour la nuit des
longs couteaux il ya de commencer à
l'extrême droite surtout merci merci
jérôme batx a accepté de commenter cette
actualité de votre parti à notre micro
merci beaucoup quant à marc philippe
daubresse est aussi votre parti dans
l'est républicain
qu'est-ce que vous inspire ce sondage ce
sondage qui donne pour la première fois
eric zemmour qualifier au second tour
devant votre candidat vous aviez bertru
jérôme bascher viens de lire on avait
klaxonné
au début de l'été avant les vacances
pour dire si on continue comme ça on va
dans le mur et nous allons dans le mur
nous sommes nous sommes en train
d'organiser notre défaite parce que nous
n'avons pas anticipé les choses et qu'
il est plus que temps que comme l'ont
fait les socialistes avec leurs
procédures comme l'ont fait les
écologistes à leur procédure nous nous
ayons une procédure rapide pour désigner
notre candidat
évidemment que monsieur zemmour est un
candidat de l'ex inquiète quand vous
voyez un eczéma rocio écoutez moi c'est
non eric zemmour est en train vous le
voyez bien de deux pompes
essentiellement son électorat sur celui
de madame le pen bon nous je rappelle
que jacques chirac et nicolas sarkozy
avait fait un cordon sanitaire vis-à-vis
du front national nous devons réaffirmer
ce cordon sanitaire nous n'avons ni la
même conception ni les mêmes valeurs de
société il faut le dire très vite et
très clairement à notre électorat mais
notre électorat ce qu'ils nous demandent
en contrepartie cette sortie rapidement
une équipe de france avec un capitaine
de l'équipe de france à sa tête et donc
le moi je les dirai pt ro reaap été
signé la motion karoutchi le 4 décembre
c'est beaucoup trop tard 2 décembre
c'est austerlitz mais le 4 décembre
c'est la moskova à quoi faut arrêter
donc c'est maintenant qu'il faut décider
c'est ce que le message qu'on va porter
ce soir un certain nombre au bureau
politique pierre ouzoulias ce peut être
un mot sur eric zemmour quand vous voyez
exim aussi haut dans les sondages c'est
17 18% selon un sondage harris
interactive qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire qu'est ce que ça dit peut-être
de la société française ou de ceux qui
font les sondages de l'horreur de
l'horreur je suis petit fils de
résistants une partie de ma famille
n'est pas revenu des camps de
concentration et quand j'entends
quelqu'un qui nous explique aujourd'hui
que le maréchal pétain à protéger les
juifs le jeu ressemble horreur je
ressemble l'horreur c'est souiller la
mémoire de ces millions de juifs c'est
anne il est tout le travail qu'on a pu
faire après la shoah pour que jamais ne
revienne cette époque monsieur zemmour
est quelqu'un qui est représentatif de
l'extrême droite française qui a mené
notre pays au chaos au déshonneur et à
la barbade i il faut en effet
qu'aujourd'hui un front républicain se
dresse contre lui ce personnage
représente ce qu'il ya de plus sombre
dans notre histoire quand il dit des
choses comme ça à la télévision c'est de
l'imposture ces deux mensonges vos
collègues ne devraient pas lui permettre
de proférer de pareilles mensonges
devant les les téléspectateurs donc je
suis effrayé et après si vous me
permettrez même si vous me permettez à
un propos un peu plus léger et
sincèrement je sais pas si on peut le
faire aller mais monsieur zemmour est un
tartuffe il nous il nous explique qu'il
ferait que tous les gens qui vivent en
france et un prénom français mais son
nom qui est un très beau nom zemmour ça
vient d'une d'une racine c'est mythique
qui veut dire le joueur de flûte le
pipeau donc si monsieur zemmour
considère que tous les français doivent
porter d nom francisé qui change de nom
et je lui propose eric pipeau je pense
que ça sonne très très bien donc il a
jusqu'au bout et qu'ils commencent par
s'appliquer ces méthodes scandaleuses à
lui-même moi je pense que la nation
c'est pas sa nation c'est pas la race la
nation c'est la citoyenneté tout le
monde des citoyens et a le droit dans un
rapport direct avec la république de
participer à l'activité de la république
voilà racheter mal ce front républicain
il est nécessaire aujourd'hui votre
candidate anne hidalgo elle à 6% eric
zemmour 17 10% sur les sondages ça vous
inquiète aussi deux choses d'abord aucun
sondage à 8 ou sept mois n'a trouvé le
résultat donc je pense que attention à
sage on est tous addict aux sondages
montrent bien qu'ils ne se réalisent
jamais si je vous évoquez thaler mon
collègue évoqué jacques chirac souvenez
vous une émission s'élève à 14 avait
demandé de se retirer il devient
quelques semaines après pour novembre il
était à 14 tout à fait donc premier
point des sondages c'est bien tout le
monde et regagne enfin c'est une pro ça
ne dit rien du résultat final deuxième
chose moi je porte ce qu'il faut
démontrer les uns des autres que nous
avons un projet de société il faut
combattre celui que propose eric zemmour
ce qu'il dit moi je suis d'accord avec
tout ce qu'il dit alors d'ailleurs il ya
ce qu'ils disent qu'ils ne dit pas mais
ce qu'il faut débattre avec la région
rien ce qu'il dit ce qu'il ne dit pas il
a des obsessions il croit que vous lui
montrez que ce qu'ils disent sur
l'immigration super heureuse que la
france c'est faux donc il faut combattre
politiquement ces propos là donc faut
pas autre chose et puis après est ce
qu'il ne dit pas irisé manquer ce qu'ils
nous disent sûrs on l'évoquait thaler
les salaires le pouvoir d'achat la
culture et c'est donc moi je pense que
le problème n'est pas eric zemmour le
problème il est simplement que chaque
candidat doit et c'est ce que fait anne
hidalgo déployer ses propositions
déploie sa vision assez française pas
vis-à-vis de pierre ou jacques mais aux
français mais ce qui le délivre avec
eric zemmour c'est toujours la question
non c'est votre question c'est vrai sur
nous je faisais ma réponse moi je pense
qu'il faut surtout débattre avec les
français élection présidentielle c'est
pas un concours entre les uns les autres
c'est que chacun présente aux français
sa vision concrètement comment quand je
suis aujourd'hui caissière à auchan
quand je suis par exemple dans les hauts
fourneaux parce que je suis je suis un
ouvrier
quand je suis quelqu'un de précaires etc
etc comment tel ou tel candidat change
ma vie et quand anne hidalgo 10 - avec
moi la question des salaires sera
prioritaire je ferai en sorte qu'ils
augmentent les profs à la d exemple et
d'autres et bien là pour le coup pour
moi c'est une vraie réponse est donc la
bonne réponse c'est ces propositions la
aux français je crois ne rentrons pas
dans un piège qui serait de faire
directement ou de pouls d'un autre le
centre du débat ce n'est pas le vrai il
a pas de projet de société donc chacun
doit déployer ses propositions marc
philippe daubresse même question est-ce
qu'il faut débattre avec eric zemmour
est ce que xavier bertrand doit aller et
des basses semaine que les télés 24
heures sur 24 dans leur ensemble sur
médiatise monsieur zemmour donc c'est la
fnsa les comptes a neigé pas que c'est
la faute des télés vous allez comme
toujours avec les télévisions vous avez
un phénomène qui surgit oui il ya une
dynamique zemmour c'est clair qui
reprend tout ce qui a de plus sordide
dans la société française je le dis
comme je pense moi c'est contraire
complètement à toutes mes malheurs je
vous le redis clairement et donc quelque
part cette dynamique là la presse s'en
fait l'écho sauf qu'à l'amplifient la
presse est un amplificateur il est grand
temps que la presse maintenant que la
plupart des formations politiques et
j'espère la nôtre rapidement vont avoir
leur champion et leur équipe qu'elle
tend le micro vers les autres et
quelques pistes chacun explique ces
projets de société qu'on décide en
consciente monsieur zemmour a pris de
l'avancé pourquoi parce que monsieur des
musées mort depuis trois semaines on
n'entend que lui même ont ils fait la
couverture de paris match parce qu'ils
en train de se baigner avec une jeune
femme ça prend une heure dans les
télévisions excusez moi de vous dire que
non ce phénomène amplificateur il faut
que ça cesse et qu'on pose un certain
nombre de vrais débats de société après
chacun fera son choix en démocrate mais
aujourd'hui nous ne sommes plus dans une
démocratie
clair on est dans une sur médiatisation
d'un homme comme si on voulait que ce
soit le champion face au président de la
république salue bien sûr répond quand
même à certaines inquiétudes des
français ce que vous êtes d'accord tous
les trois là dessus ou par email
sauf que bien sûr qu'il ya des
inquiétudes bien sûr qu'est la rébellion
bien sûr qu'elle est le gilet jaune mais
ces inquiétudes ne trouvent pas leurs
réponses dans des réponses sordide qui
détruisent le projet fondamental de
société de démocratie et de république
de nation française et c'est ça qu'il
faut qu'on dise chacun avec nos projets
différents mais c'est ça qu'il faut
qu'on dise maintenant aux efforts rachis
thèmes allant de minutes rappelons
d'abord il ya ce qui n'est pas possible
dans un débat politique quand vous
faites du révisionnisme ou qu'on ait de
quoi vous êtes vous êtes condamné pour
incitation à la haine raciale vous êtes
disqualifié bon après moi en fait je
sais pas qui pose les bonnes questions
je sais que moi j'entends ce que 10 des
français sur le projet d'achat sur un
sentiment d'insécurité à sion et c'est
damien castera il n'y a pas de problème
mais posons les débats des bâtons mais
encore une fois entendez ce que nous
proposons c'est ça qu'il faut retenir
nous avons des propositions la campagne
débute et nous verrons à la fin ce que
choisiront les français moi je fais très
largement confiance aux françaises et
aux français pour se dire qu'à la fin il
faut offrir des hommes et des femmes qui
seront diriger le pays et qui seront
faire en sorte que lié à une vie unité
nationale et non pas la haine des uns
contre les autres on va découvrir une
nouvelle figure du sénat yann
chanterelle que vous connaissez sans
doute racheter mal dans mon groupe
sénateurs socialistes des français de
l'étranger qui vient de faire son entrée
au sénat il est avec vous quand un
qu'elle mais comment se passent ces
premiers pas au sénat finalement oui on
va lui poser une question effectivement
style sur ses premiers pas
l on a entendu vous avez posé une
question d'actualité alors une question
tout ça parce que c'est impressionnant
de prendre la parole devant tous ses
nouveaux collègues devant le
gouvernement avec une émission en plus
ce qui est diffusé à la télévision quand
on vient d'être élu sénateur oui c'est
un baptême du feu surtout je suis arrivé
il ya deux jours du canada donc avec un
petit décalage horaire mais je pense que
c'est important d'être immédiatement
dans l'action pour pour mes compatriotes
aussi bien établis hors de france que je
représente et nos concitoyens qui vivent
en france j'ai pu visiter ce lieu le
palais du luxembourg c'est un lieu assez
impressionnant a là encore qu'est ce que
vous êtes dit lorsque vous êtes arrivé
ici lorsque je me suis dit c'est que il
faudrait que cette institution soit
ouverte à la parole citoyenne sa gelée
vraiment à coeur tel qu'elles remettent
le citoyen au coeur de la vie publique
et nos institutions se doivent d'être
les plus ouverte possible parce qu'elles
sont au service de nos compatriotes et
je pense que ça c'est un axe important
pour moi c'est la vie politique est un
peu des fois des considéré par nos
concitoyens ça peut être à juste titre
par moment et je pense qu'il faut
justement les réimpliquer en leur
permettant d'ouvrir des espaces en
ouvrant les lieux dans le pays dans
lequel je vis par exemple au québec
qu'ils ont possibilité de talent et dans
les restaurants d'avoir des auditions
citoyenne tirés au sort et c'est des
choses comme ça que je vais amener au
parlement également à travers le
parlementaire de combat que je souhaite
être est ici il nous reste une minute
pour un prendre un peu à vous connaître
on l'a dit vous allez sujet avec karachi
tu es mal au groupe socialiste quel est
votre positionnement est ce que vous
êtes dans l'opposition frontale à
emilienne macro est ce que vous pouvez
être constructif par rapport à l'air m
bah moi déjà quand je vois ce qui a été
fait jusque jusqu'à aujourd'hui ça fait
maintenant quatre ans c'est quand même
une dégradation forte au niveau de la
france de toutes les politiques
publiques les services publics une
libéralisation accrue de la france et
donc oui je serai comme je vous ai dit
un parlementaire de combat pour me
battre aussi contre l'extrême droite
isation de la vie politique à l'heure
actuelle la vie politique tourne autour
des sujets pour moi qui sont des sujets
de déviation des vrais problèmes et je
pense que c'est important qu'on parle de
la réalité vécue par nos compatriotes
c'est le pouvoir d'achat c'est des
questions très concrètes c'est pas les
immigrés le problème le problème c'est
la fiche de paie c'est les conditions
sociales dans laquelle vivent la plupart
de nos compatriotes et c'est à ça qu'il
faut répondre et le gouvernant
malheureusement n'y répond pas c'était
exactement le débat qui avait lieu en ce
moment sur le plateau de public sénat la
dégradation selon certains sénateurs ici
en plateau du débat médiatique c'est
aussi votre sentiment notamment vu de
l'étranger oui bah vu de l'extérieur je
peux vous dire c'est triste de voir
l'état du débat public français j'ai pas
seul à dire je pense que n'importe qui
qui regardent sage c'est déplorable donc
je pense qu'il est temps justement de
redonner un peu de dignité au débat
public et de parler d ivresse des vraies
choses et des vraies affaires eh bien
merci 1 6 h entre elles pour m première
interview au micro de public sénat et
donc on le dit vous aller siéger à la
commission de la culture ici à la
chambre haute voilà steve pour cette
rencontre avec un chanteur qui faisait
donc ses premiers pas au sénat merci
beaucoup quand il nous reste très peu de
temps messieurs j'ai une question yann
chanterelle disait que l'immigré c'était
pas le problème émigrés s'était pas
l'immigration s'était pas le thème de
cette campagne si pour vous quel doit
être le thème quel sera le sujet
principal cette élection présidentielle
pierre auzias élections dans six mois
maintenant il faut sauver l'humanité
fausse mais il faut sauver l'humanité
l'humanité social l'humanité
environnemental c'est un défi majeur
auquel notre humanité n'a jamais été
exposées dans de telles conditions
oui j'étais mal pareil moi j'irai la
justice sociale écologique et
démocratique
et d'abord les salaires je crois que
c'est là sur le sujet sera le plus
important la fille d'andré moi je pense
qu'on est arrivé au bout de notre modèle
social et qui font horaire vers en t1
qui comporte les mêmes justice que celui
d'après 1945 et je pensais aussi que un
goon eu de gros problèmes c'est un
problème de gouvernance on est passé
vite sur ce qu'a dit madame de
montchanin tout à l'heure mais la
réforme de la haute fonction publique de
l'état c'est un vrai sujet tout à fait
la réforme de la manière dont cet état
hyper centralisé et gouverner c'est un
vrai sujet parce que nous côtoyons
attendent beaucoup plus précis
institutionnelle selon louis alors c'est
pas sexy je le sais bien mais les hawks
nos concitoyens attendent de
l'efficacité et de la justice or
l'efficacité n'est pas au rendez vous
avec un état hyper centralisé comme on a
aujourd'hui donc 6ème république hwa jai
pas des 6ème république j'ai dit voilà
on est en train de voter une loi qui
n'est pas une loi de décentralisation
est on en train couper la tête à des
préfets qui quelques pas en besoin de
plus de déconcentration et donc ça c'est
un vrai sujet sur le terrain parce que
sinon vous pouvez voir j'étais j'ai fait
deux grands plans pour l'état quand
j'étais ministre pouvait avoir des
grands plans si ça n'arrive pas jusqu
aux citoyens c'est fichu merci merci
beaucoup à tous les trois merci d'avoir
été sur ce plateau pour commenter pour
décrypter ces questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
c'est la fin de cette émission 16h59
vous avez rendez vous tout de suite avec
florence parly vous allez parler
finances avec la ministre des armées l
ai entendu cet après midi par les
sénateurs dessinateur qui veulent savoir
ce que prépare le gouvernement pour le
budget de l'année prochaine en matière
de défense nationale regarder cette
addition on en reparle juste après
[Musique]
le premier sentiment mais c'est
certainement le plus important c'est un
sentiment de satisfaction au sens où
cette mission défense
frôlé 41 milliards d'euros fin vous
préciserez